That sound that you hear, ladies
and gentlemen. It's not a real cat.
That was actually me.
So if you're allergic to cats,
don't fucking freak out right now,
man.
The joke will experience the
one with the fuck's going on.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by [inaudible] dot com.
Today's the last day today being Tuesday,
October 16th.
If you use the, the, the, uh,
the codeword follow on it,
you'll save 20% off of any supplements.
If you follow them on Twitter and
you use that follow on it 20% off.
No, no, no, no, no. You
know one either or do both.
20% is what I'm saying. Normally
it's double what the Code Brogan is.
Wow. Yeah. So it was just today.
So go buy yourself some fucking pills
that make your brain better, dude.
All right. Get some, get some
shroom tech. Get some knew.
Mood knew mood is,
uh,
one of the best supplements that we have
because it really actually makes you
feel better. I mean, it sounds crazy,
but there are supplements that
enhance your brain chemistry.
That's not what they really sound like
when they're rolling around and magical.
But it is,
it's five f five HTP and the whole
trip to fan and it's got sort of a time
release quality to it because five HTP
is what turns into Serotonin and which
what your body uses to make
serotonin and l tryptofan.
It's what your body
converts in the five HTP.
So there's like a time release aspect
of new mood and you take them at night.
Uh, you can take them during
the day too. But most people,
most people take it at night before
they go to bed and you'll feel great.
It helps the way you sleep,
it helps your dreams. Um,
Alpha brain will fuck with your
dreams for sure. That's one thing. If,
if we just sold them just as dream pills,
forget about what it can
do for your memory and uh,
all the other different shit
that they can do for him.
But just what it does for your dreams.
You'll have really trippy dreams.
Most likely meet for me.
They're much more lucid
and I remember them more.
For some reason my
retention is way better.
I took some last night and had crazy
dreams. Yeah. Yeah. What'd you dream?
I can't talk about it, but it's with Dan
at or on mine. Who's a friend of mine.
It was really awkward. It's
really awkward. The dream
about her sexually. Yeah.
That'd be funny.
If she wasn't a porn star.
That'd be hilarious if she wasn't in
like how many gang bang films this shit
done? They're like violent gang
bang one. So when you like her,
she's a nice person. Like,
oh, I enjoy being around her.
It wasn't like a sex dream like that.
It was like,
it was like a romantic dream that became
sexual and it was very awkward. Oh,
it was a romance.
A love thing.
You have some secret love and Alpha brain
brought it up. That's beautiful, man.
She, everybody needs love.
Even porn starts need love.
They need love more than anybody.
Maybe you're the guy, dude.
You're the guy to bring it out.
What do you do?
Do Animated Gifs in fucking audio.
Hey, I'm animated sparco gifts.
Please don't do that. Okay. For my
space. Bringing pays back pitches,
it's still up.
You can go.
Is this people on an everyday I logged
in the other day in the end, uh,
I was trying to do some
stuff and it was not working.
And then somebody said that that they're
selling my space and like restarting it
and you're just going to lose all
your stuff that was there. Oh.
So they're going to try a new company
is going to take it one more time.
Like could cool down know if that's true.
But it's what's making just with someone
told him. So does he Google it? No.
Ne He just reports. I don't even want
to Google my space. I'll ping it.
Well maybe I really don't give a fuck.
You're fucking shady. I love it. Uh,
on a.com he used the code name. This
is, well, by the time you hear this,
if it's on iTunes too late,
so you use a code name Brogan and he
was still save 10% off any and all
supplements we now have as of today,
the Blendtec blenders in um,
there significant in the last one that
with the manufacturer retail prices,
I think it's like when we sell them for
more than a hundred dollars less than
the retailers. Yeah, we're you, we're
trying to sell shit as cheap as possible.
The,
the,
the idea behind on it is to
sell you guys the best process.
Yeah. The, the actual price.
The MSRP is six 59 and we
sell them for four 54. Wow.
That's go the best possible shit
or the cheapest we can sell it.
So like the kettle bells, that's the best
possible kettlebells we couldn't buy.
They have nice fat handles are
excellent. We made, there's solid steel,
these fucking iron things.
They'll last forever.
You don't need to buy
them once in your life.
And these giant iron
cannonballs you swing around,
there'll be your extra exercise equipment
forever. Same with the battle ropes.
You never going to break him. They're
giant ropes that you use to make fucking,
they pull ships and shit.
You just whip these bitches around
and you get an awesome shape. So go,
go get on that. Go, go get
on it. Okay. Just do it.
Oh Brian going to make an animated
one of that and we need, I know Brian,
I know Brian animated like an
animated Gif if you do need to do,
I had a lot of fun playing with the
grass fed guy yesterday. He was awesome.
He was a really cool and interesting
like I was smart as fuck.
It scared the shit out of me. I've
been thinking about it. It was like,
you know when you see a movie
and sometimes you're like,
God, that was good. Maybe.
Then there's other movies you see and
you think about it for like the rest of
the night. You wouldn't talk about
it while you're eating. You know?
It's kind of like that guy. Like I, I'm,
I want to listen to it again and try to
dissect what that guy was saying. Yeah.
Well let's talk about that later.
Let's get through this fucking
rancid commercial. We're stuck in.
Go buy some shit. Go to desk
squad. Dot TV and buy some shit.
The November 11 tickets are sold out
though. You fuck heads. You missed out.
You can't go to sea now.
Thomson [inaudible] it was Brendan Walsh,
but Brendan and Brian,
it's not completely asleep over there's a,
there's a date and show
now I November 8th.
[inaudible] there might be
a second Columbia show. Uh,
cause that one's almost sold out if not
sold out already. It's far enough away.
She put on tickets for his episode,
decides if you haven't seen Thompson
Thompson grow right now is like on fire.
This kid is fucking hilarious. He's, he's
one of the best comics in the country.
He isn't taught, if you want to talk
about like an underappreciated God.
It's hilarious. Thompson.
That's who I believe.
He doesn't get like talked
into consideration is like
the best comics out there.
He makes me laugh as much as anybody.
He's a beautiful man.
He's a sexy beast and he makes them
with Doug Benson and Tony Hinchcliffe,
it's gonna be read. It's going to
be fun. It's gotta be fun to go.
Go check that shit out. Ohio. Fuck heads.
The end of the world show is still on.
Tickets are available. Go to live nation.
You could find them. You could find them
somewhere buried in my Twitter feed,
but it's going to be honey honey band
the first time we've ever done anything
with a band, but they're so cool. How
could we not so honey, honey band,
Joey motherfucking Coco Diaz,
Doug,
Stan hope and me and it's December 21st,
2012 at the Wiltern theater in La and
shit's going to get crazy bitches.
Hey,
when is the Mayan calendar actual Cli on?
Where's the my own clock with actual
time? Is it like, is it, is it,
are there times at like 12 1212 or
don't think they ha ha.
I think you have to take their calendar
and then you have to corresponded to a,
our, our, you know, whatever it's
called. The green. What does the,
what does Arconic calendar called?
What is the technical term but Gorian
Gregorian. Yeah. So I don't think,
I don't think we should talk about
that in the middle of commodity. So
hire at dash primate Dotcom
t shirts are back in stock.
So go to death squad. Dot. TV.
Brian's t shirts are available and hired
primate is all monkeys and mushrooms
and their software. Um, I'm a silly man.
All right ladies and men, this podcast,
we're going to try to keep it as,
as light on the gloom and doom as
possible because the subject matter is
absolutely fucking hideous.
It's not tangible, right?
It's crap. Now, this wasn't a,
this isn't a when thanks though
for, sorry. Weeks of 10. One.
Okay.
Experience.
First of all, thank you guys
for enduring those commercials.
This is the least professional piece of
broadcast and you'll ever be a part of.
We're trying to be as minimalized and is,
uh,
easily dismissed as we can.
So we just,
it was just going to do bad stuff from
here on out. Yeah. Have signed to lay low.
There's too much bad
information out there.
The more I read about what's going on,
the more you read about the government
anymore. He read about corruption and,
and, and, and censorship and what,
what's really going on behind the scenes.
It's fucking depressing. Do you guys feel
that? Who I'm talking to is Abby Martin.
David Seaman. And I'm
sorry, David's kind of your,
what is the exact term is online
campaign campaign manager,
which named Buddy Dell.
Cameron. Tell Cameron, Dale
Dale Dale down pack like Dell,
like the computer. Right. Do you ever
use, do you use Dell Dell products?
We feel silly.
Uh,
if I was using like a rogue and laptop,
but going to that bitch, same name.
So I would feel weird about
that. Doesn't bother you. No.
Good for you man. I mean, I'm not sure
it's short for Cordell. Oh, Cordell. Oh,
okay. Okay. But I'm a junior and that's
just too confusing sometimes for my,
your father talk with a
southern accent police.
I guess that'd be awesome if he's Cordell
and Cordell for Dale Dale junior come
over here,
touchy you about life.
Um, you guys are all very young
and you're all very idealistic.
You're all very, uh, uh, you're, you're,
you're the new breed of
journalists and we're,
we're seeing this because of what's going
on because there's so much censorship
and because CNN and Fox News and they've
gotten to be what you got to think of
as untrustworthy sources in for the
simple fact that they don't concentrate on
everything. There's a lot of shit. It's
really important that they don't cover.
But meanwhile they'll find the
time to cover ridiculous shit.
They'll find the time to,
to cover some nonsense celebrity
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West Story.
They'll find that time,
they'll fit it in,
but they won't find the
time to discuss the NDA.
They won't find the time to discuss these
buildings that they're making in Utah
where they're going to store everybody's
information that they need to be
discussing this. That's what
journalism is supposed to be for.
Everyone knows this now
and because of you guys,
because of this new breed of young
kids who grew up with the Internet,
he grew up with this massive access to
information and this model that they've
got in place for how shit runs is whack.
And it's not gonna work.
It's not going to work.
It's like almost like a religious model.
It's like you have to believe in it as
a religion and you have to trust the
government and full faith for it to
work at all. And the only way they're,
they're,
they're actually getting people to go
along with that is by connecting it to
religion that connected to,
to the really simple minded folks,
that whole God and government thing.
And you know, God's on our side.
And it really does become sort
of a religious, a variable.
It becomes like the
reason why it's working.
It's because we've got this
weird wacky thing in us.
We're willing to believe shit
that doesn't make any sense.
And there's a lot of you guys that are
coming up that aren't doing that. You're,
you're, you're standing up
and you're saying this is,
the information that you're getting
is not exactly what's happening.
And they're lying through omission also.
Yes.
It's not so much that they're running
stories saying don't worry about Nda.
It's that they're not covering it at all.
Yeah.
And I think that's something else
is more important. So instead it's,
let's talk about Mitt Romney's tax returns
from the 90s and let's not focus on
something that is happening right now.
How did that happen? How did they do or
they just bought and paid for? I mean,
what is it?
Some of them, I think that's,
yeah, I mean, it's, it's,
it's not for truth telling.
I mean, they can legally lie. So it's just
a profit making industry. They're not,
they're not supposed to
tell you the fucking news. I
mean, they sell shit to you.
They sell fear and they sell
sensationalism. That's what sells.
There's huge entertainment
value to it. And that's why
they have somebody watching it.
When did the sellout begin?
Yeah, during the deregulation
era when we had, you know,
it went from like 60 companies to now
five corporations control everything that
you see and read in the main stream
and general electric. I mean,
the biggest fucking weapons'
contractor owns MSNBC, NBC. So
ads running during news programs itself.
Like, I mean, it, it takes away from like,
the, the viewers aren't really the
customers anymore. The ad agencies are,
and the viewers were, we're more of, um,
you're the part of like a product because
that's their selling are, you know,
the fact that we're reviewing too.
So you think,
I mean,
well that would be actually a good way
to allocate government funds, right?
Wouldn't it be to have like an
independent news source that was funded
completely and totally by tax dollars and
had nothing to do with any commercials
whatsoever?
Is that what it actually is for Russia?
That's what you work for.
The Russian times is our t right? Russia
today. Rush it to them. I'm sorry.
Do they, um, are they accurate
with stuff that goes on in rush
that is questionable? Uh, they, you
know, it's like the BBC in London.
Um, so you're not going to cover Putin,
obviously, like very unfavorable,
you're probably not going to call it the
elections as being stolen or whatnot.
But in terms of rt America,
which is where I work,
we just focused wholeheartedly on American
foreign policy and domestic policy.
So that's really where my head's at.
I mean we don't see Russia going around
and colonizing the rest of the world.
So I'm kind of picking my
battles here and working for a,
they still, they still keep a
gangster in Russia. They're, yeah,
they're keeping it as gangster as any
like real evolve civilization can,
I mean, it's really good,
again, because of the Internet,
because of this access to information
that we have now and we're kind of really
seeing the true shape of these things.
Whereas before it was all
hidden behind. You know, nobody,
nobody had access to information. Nobody
knew about who, never who. I mean,
how many people actually went through
the Warren Commission report and followed
up on all the inconsistencies. How many
people have actually like read a bill?
How many people have actually, it's, it's,
it's too confusing for people on that
broadcasters that are actually,
you're going to read it and
relay the information accurately.
Exactly.
So what should it be?
Should it be that the news
is completely noncommercial?
is state funded? So because,
but you can't tell these
fuckheads where to spend money.
That's the most annoying
thing about giving out taxes.
Some of the networks don't appear to
be the networks that are supposedly
operating for profit or making decisions
that are against their own commercial
interests to instead promote propaganda,
which is worrying. You look at like,
so NDA would have been a massive story
with a lot of viewers and a lot of hits
on the online side. Right. And
why wasn't that covered? You know,
Wiki leaks is a massive
story in every possible way.
So something's happening behind the scenes
that is not purely driven by profit.
It's by,
uh, um, what's the word,
by ideology. You know,
somebody who's being told or somebody
believes that this should not be shown to
the public.
Yeah. That's where it gets really
scary is when it surpasses the,
the a moneymaking like the paypal
thing when they tried to block funds to
Bradley Manning and you're like,
you're working against your interest to
make money and to try to fucking promote
some sort of government and make money
off of that green is easier to understand.
You know what you're talking about. Like,
yeah, it's, it's, it's really confusing.
Like when you see these things like
the end date. For folks who don't know,
let's just give a brief overview of what
the NDA actually means to people just
so they know. We know why. Well,
they know, rather while we're upset,
why don't you just
explain it in that show?
Uh,
the NDA is normally passed every year.
It's our defense appropriations
bill. So, uh, pays for the troops,
salaries and all of our spending
overseas and various military things. Uh,
in this last year's bill in 2011,
they snuck in a provision section 10 21,
which appears to allow for
the imprisonment without
trial of American citizens
on suspicion alone. Uh, and that's
what has caused all the uproar.
Why was this thing snuck into something
that they pretty much need to pass?
Why did Obama claim that he wanted to
veto it? And then he withdrew his veto,
threatened sign it into law at like 11:30
PM on New Year's Eve when nobody was
paying attention. And then he
went to stay there. I said,
it was like the sneakiest move I've ever
seen in my lifetime from a president,
this single sneakiest move. And then
he issues a signing statement saying,
I did it, I have resin, I had reservations
about it, but I'm not gonna use it.
And you're like, okay, maybe he gets it.
Maybe you just had to sign it for some
reason that we don't know about a,
and then his lawyer's in court have tried
incredibly ferociously to hang on to
this power. We've seen two rounds of
that now and it's gotten very serious.
I think the next stop,
uh,
I mean it already went through a three
judge panel and the appeals court and
they ruled in his favor.
So we're getting pretty close to
the Supreme Court at this point.
I think they have to see another,
there's another round of something
that the appeals court can go through,
but it's scary that Obama
claims he doesn't want this.
And yet his lawyers are working very
diligently to make sure that he has it.
It appears to me that either they know
something that we don't know or there is
a systematic sort of a psychosis involved
in governing people and when you're in
a position where you have the
power to tell people what to do,
it does not seem like a natural position
and it seems like this us versus them
mentality that can come come about it.
It gets to a point where they're willing
to sacrifice the lives of people that
are supposed to be on their team.
They're willing to do that in
order to push their agenda.
When you hear about stuff like that
and you hear about like the false flag
events and the planned false flag of act,
a false flag event that they were going
to do an ran about operation Northwoods
in the 60s yeah,
that's well documented,
well documented that they were going to
blow up a drone airliner and it on Cuba.
They were going to arm chub and friendly's
and have them attack Guantanamo Bay
and they were going to blame all this
shit on Cuba so we could go to war with
Cuba. There were just going to kill
people. They're going to kill Americans.
They were going to kill soldiers. They're
going to attack basis. You know? I mean,
they're easily could have
been in completely innocent
Americans that have died
because these guys wanted an
excuse to get into war. Well,
why the fuck would anybody
want to do that? What is that?
What is it where you would you be
a person who was in government?
You're supposed to be the
leader of these people,
but you're doing something
that's completely contrary
to the wants and needs of
any of the people.
I think leadership has become kind of
cannibalistic where they're like, okay,
we need to keep you safe,
but in order to do that,
you have to strip you of your rights.
You're destroying the things
that the terrorist supposedly
hate us for. You know,
you're taking away our core freedoms are
turning us into a Middle Eastern regime.
Yeah, but they're consciously
doing it. They're not.
They don't believe that she is doing
this. Who is the person? Who is the group?
What is, is it follow? The money
is at the top of the food truck
machine and incorporations
control the the body elect,
not not just any corporation, it's
defense contractors, defense contractors,
Monsanto.
There's a few a keynote,
but I didn't see insatiable
urge for more control.
I mean when you have the technology
at your fingertips and it's just
exponentially growing, you just want it.
The insatiable urge to control that to,
you know, if there's facial recognition
technology, you want to seize that.
You want to fucking tap into all that
shit and just have the grid just because
you can.
I think anything
become,
you can rationalize anything you know
for them as long as it's like supporting
the business interests of the United
States as opposed to like anything else.
Like I think that there one of them,
this is not a sickness
and then it could be so pervasive
that it could be thousands of people.
It could be where people working together
along with people that signed up for
the military to supposedly
protect, you know, this country.
They could be involved in this,
this nonsense.
People are hopped up on episodes of
homeland and then actually believe they
believe their own internal
memos that people like me,
journalists and independent politicians
who don't side with one party and people
who are like fucking college students
who have backpacks and little cameras to
record stuff, that those people
are potential terrorists.
It's absolutely insane.
You start believing their own lie. Yeah.
I mean it's just nobody challenged it.
Nobody is saying no, that's
bullshit. So over time people go,
maybe this is the way it is. Maybe,
maybe these people are terrorists.
They are undermining our
system, right? Maybe,
maybe journalists are terrorists who,
so why isn't this discussion
ever going mainstream? Why?
Why has this discussion
completely avoided? But even
like unlike Bill Maher show,
they don't talk about this. Like, I mean,
what we're trying to do is
turn the mainstream and away
from the TV and bring it
over to us.
Yeah. But even, I mean, yeah, Bill Maher's
broke is the line. A lot of tickets.
I mean, you've got to find new media
has bill Maher's and brought this up?
No, Bill Maher fucking pulled
out his giant checkbook.
Gave $1 million to Obama's fucking Super
Pac Dune though Mars totally toeing the
line. I mean it's sad, you know,
you can fall in line with so much of what
he says and at the end of the day he's
just like, and that's why
you need to donate money to
Obama. And you're like, what?
Yeah, I don't get it. I mean
maybe it's to get guests on.
Maybe if it doesn't play the game,
you can't run a show the
way he wants to run a show.
I think it's a status symbol.
I think so.
I think people donate large amounts of
money to political campaigns just so that
people know that they did. Yeah,
you're right. Well, no, not everyone,
but I think a lot of people do that.
It's like philanthropy for like people
like charities, hunty philanthropists,
philanthropies, braggy and shit about
their philanthropy. Yeah, it's the same.
Same thing to me.
I think,
well,
here's the reason that the dialogue is
not inserted in the mainstream because
the problem with the media other than of
course the fact that it's controlled by
corporations and that it's partisan.
So it's divide and conquer.
I mean they bring up these really divisive
issues that no one can agree on in a
country of 380 million people just to
keep us fighting when really we can all
agree on the huge issues that we
don't want to fucking, you know,
invade the entire planet and spend,
you know,
just waste millions and trillions
of dollars by killing people.
I mean I think we can all agree on those
things, but they like to keep us a,
you know, fighting with each other. And
so you have these networks like MSNBC,
Fox News,
CNN,
they're all partisan and they all push
these narratives that don't broaden up
the scope to undermine the actual
rhetoric of the establishment line,
which is really,
you know,
they tow that line to keep people
in line and that's the problem.
They pull abortion out of the pocket
cause that's the way it's not going to be
resolved next month or next year.
It's always going to be something we're
47 or 48% of the people believe this one
thing and 47 or 48% of the people
believe this one thing and then two or 3%
don't really give a shit.
Gay Rights and abortion,
everything's going to be like
that until the end of the time.
Yes. It will never make
marriage legal federally ever.
They won't because then they
lose that thing to argue about.
It's like they'll always figure out a way
to make that a stupid issue that comes
up.
Well that's what I was
telling them last night.
Like I think maybe a lot of conservative
politicians don't really want abortion,
um,
to be illegal because it would take away
like the one big polarizing issue that
they have with their, with
their bring brings the ground
springs, the crowds like,
yeah.
I mean
did he wrote Dajani laid the Tennessee
who is like pro life and then force his
mistress to have an abortion.
Pretty fucking funny.
Sounds like a classy caught up on that
shit. I'm like outlawed contraception,
but he had put a bill through to
fund like animal contraception.
It's all this self loathing game.
Yeah,
you've got to worry about anybody that
really cares that other people were doing
things that have no effect on them and
you wrap it up in your religion and
whatever you want to wrap it up.
Then if you're going after
people for what they enjoy doing,
there's something wrong with you.
It's just that simple. Right.
Saw the bill of rights.
Such an important thing.
You have these rights
doesn't really matter to me.
The government thinks that it would
make us safer to take them away.
That's not what you can do.
This is the safest time we've ever known.
There's never been more safety.
There's never been like a peace America.
We could go even in this
fucking terrible economy,
like it's safer to live today than it
has been to ever live ever on earth.
You know? And we still act like
the fucking sky is falling.
We're going to snatch away rights
and build up military camps.
Will you know what it is? Man?
It's not even red scare. I mean,
what it is is,
uh,
a business that's trying to
stay in business and there's
only one way to stay in
business. You got to ramp up the
fucking military action side.
You want to make a lot of money
and sell a lot of fucking tanks.
I one ramp up the military action bringing
home our number one export weapons.
How the fuck can we still, you
know, we have to sell that shit.
We have to sell that shit.
They're selling tanks were just sitting
there collecting dust that we don't use.
There's massive, massive amounts of
money. We make iPods and Predator drones,
we don't even mail make the iPods
designed in California.
Well in Brazil I was just in Brazil and
apparently they make iPods and iPhones
there as well. So if you bring one over,
like if you're a Brazilian and you have,
when they want to make sure that you
didn't go and buy an American one and then
come over to Brazil because that fucks
with their economy because the Brazilian
ones are like a little bit more expensive.
So I guess they give you a hard time.
It's like this thing of the Supreme
Court is looking at this fall,
the first sale doctrine, uh, where uh,
it could challenge your right to resell
like your iPhone or your car or anything,
anything that you've bought. You'd
have to get permission from like Ford,
can I resell this car to this third
party now that I no longer wanted? What?
Because uh,
you should bring up the details of it.
I'm going to mess up the details.
It's really sick about that.
Is it only really affects businesses
and or like small businesses,
it doesn't really affect like,
I mean of course I could always walk next
door and saw my car to my neighbor so
it's not really going
to affect me personally,
but it's going to just like trash a
bunch of Internet, it's going to destroy.
There's Ebay would immediately go.
There's an issue with electric cars
as well that people aren't taking any
consideration.
A lot of people think there's some how
or another going to be free from Karma if
they get an electric car.
One of it,
it takes a lot of oil to build
and make an electric car.
But two is electric cars run on lithium
ion batteries and lithium ion batteries
come from places like the Congo and a lot
of times they're dug out of the ground
by little kids and that's
just a fucking fact.
And you can use your laptop
and your cell phone all day,
but it's very likely that somewhere
along the chain someone was abused.
I mean literally down to like the
most inhuman type thing you do.
Like you turn someone into a slave,
you turn someone in the working slave for
you, you make them do that. Like that.
The breakdown of the highest expression
of technology we have available.
If you follow its path at the end of it,
as a kid in Africa digging in the ground,
it's really hard to corporate just
in like a world. It's so like, yeah.
And also a big place where they
found a gigantic stash of lithium is
Afghanistan. The trillion
dollar minerals. Yeah.
So there's a reason why they're there.
There's a bunch of reasons why they want
to control Afghanistan and almost none
of them have to do with some dudes and a
dressed up like during the fucking star
wars movie, San People,
thousand dudes with guns.
That is not why we're there.
That's fucking bananas.
If you believe that you're
absolutely out of your fucking mind.
There's a massive amount of heroin
there and there's a massive amount of
minerals and the heroine is the craziest
one because that's the one that makes
people go, oh, you just
crossed into crazy land son.
Do you think the United States government
would be involved in selling heroin?
You know what? We don't
grow it here. So yeah,
I don't see a lot of it around
pharmaceutical companies
need to opium late techs
to manufacturer pills and the
Pharma lobby is fucking huge here.
And I mean opn, 90% of the world's
heroin comes from Afghanistan now. Yeah.
And we know when I talked to Shane Smith
from vice.com he was breaking down from
me in numbers.
How much more heroin is available
now and how easy it is to get.
And it's a direct correlation.
Cine United States being involved with
Afghanistan, that's when it started.
It's like so transparent.
It's just in your face.
There's videos of soldiers walking down
poppy fields with machine guns and for
the soldiers, they must feel like this
is not what I fucking king here for.
You know, I thought I was going
over here to fight bad guys.
I mean mom protected poppy seed.
What's crazy is I've seen a lot of people,
uh,
who are excited before they go over there.
I've yet to read a single
account and you know,
a credible publication saying like,
I went over there and it was
a great experience. You know,
I haven't seen that at once.
Not even one time.
You think if that happened that they
would promote that a lot. You know,
but I never hear that
and maybe it's out there.
I'm sure like one of your listeners
has had that, but I don't hear that.
I hear horrific stories. I heard a lot
of horrific stories from Iraq as well.
There's a guy, uh, there's, you know,
there's videos of these veterans that
sit down, I forget the name of the group,
a rack.
It might be that,
but he was just telling all the different
stories of the people they killed and
why they killed him and
how they're, uh, sergeant,
whoever it was was going to
give them extra days off.
They killed somebody with a knife,
you know,
and you hear shit like this and
you're like, whoa. Like this is like,
they're just promoting like a bunch of
assassins to just run through streets and
kill people.
You know,
they seen the photos of people
holding a little kid's head up,
the kids like naked and he shot and
the guy smiling next to him, like,
you just shot a deer. Have you seen that?
Yeah, man, that's, that's our soldiers.
You know, if that's at all
possible, even even for one guy,
we need to hit the brakes on this thing
and figure out what the fuck we're doing.
Because it's not just that
we're making money. Okay.
It's not just someone's making money,
they're making psychos. They're making,
they're making people that are probably
never going to be the same again.
Look at what they do to the,
some of the inmates at Guantanamo,
they put them in a sensory deprivation.
And then this one dude in 2006,
he had to see a dentist, I think his
name is Jose Padilla. And, and uh,
when he was out in the outside world,
they put headphones on him and goggles so
that he could not see or hear anything.
And he started going into convulsions
because his mind is so fucked at this
point from no,
no,
no stimulation over a course of like a
year or something that he's just totally
gone inside.
And when he spoke with his lawyers,
he thought that they were interrogators
pretending to be lawyers. So he's like,
he's gone. They can't,
they can't even let it go.
Let that go because you've totally
fried his mind. And now he,
if he wasn't before,
now he certainly is a fucking psycho.
How long did they have them
in there like that for?
Uh, I don't want to miss
like give you the wrong time,
but it's a lot like a long time.
Like hundreds or thousands. Yeah.
Well the media likes to paint
these people was like, oh,
they're just a few bad apples,
you know,
England or whatever the
fuck that woman's name was.
He was like pointing at the dude with
the hood on his face. And you're like,
but Rumsfeld's tort, like memos circling
Shit. And he's like more of this,
more of this. I mean, it's totally fucking
systemic. And the chain of command,
I mean,
these people are,
you're going to place a
lot of the blame on the,
on the people that are keeping the
soldiers over there because you've got to
imagine like being in a war
zone for that extended period.
Now I'm not like excusing the, some
of the most more horrific acts. Like,
obviously that's, you know, those people
had some issues before they got there.
But, um, you know,
if you keep those soldiers over there
for what had been at war for a decade,
I mean eventually, you know,
it's going to, cause, I mean,
I'm sure there's the number of people
coming back with psychological issues is
skyrocket.
I'm sure I'll continue to go up to
outnumbered deaths in battle. Yeah.
Isn't that incredible that
just, that number alone? I mean,
has that been this discussed?
No, I seriously doubt.
How could you not talk about that?
That's a big issue. It's a huge issue.
It should be on the,
because they want to pretend like the
government gives a shit about the troops.
That's why the whole
thing's very shocking.
It's very shocking when you got this far
that comes back to Nda and because some
of the funding for the NDA covers like
veterans benefits for veterans.
And so it's when they're talking
about attacking on ride ons,
like the indefinite detention section,
um, they're basically holding,
um, like veterans'
benefits and pay for, um,
for soldiers like hostage.
And they're like, you know,
we have to pass this through. Or they're
using it as an excuse like Obama did.
Like we have to pass this
through otherwise are
veterans are our, you know,
our soldiers aren't you?
You get paid and like,
well why don't you just remove that
and we'll go ahead and say, okay,
how is it legal to package a bunch
of shit together and have it count?
Welcome to Congress believably ridiculous,
shove things in there that make no sense,
that are like really bad and shove it
into something called the Patriot Act
second earlier about the knee,
how they, how they name buildings.
And like there's one where it
basically like, um, it makes, uh,
ISP Internet service providers like
log all of your activities so that the
government, like whatever, like the
FBI could access that if it needed to.
I think it's like a period
of two years and the,
that's what the bill does
and what the bill was called.
It was like the child protecting,
protecting children from predators,
molesters act, you know, and like,
who's going to vote against that?
If you vote against it, they'll slam
you in the media. Of course, like,
like Fox News for election,
the commercial is going to be like,
he voted against the anti child
Molester Act. He loves pedophile. Yeah.
Obviously. What I wanted to
say really fast about the, um,
what's so crazy about it is they
have these ride ons or add ons.
The section 10 21 and Obama
supporters claimed that, well, he was,
he was shoved in a corner. If
he didn't, if he didn't sign it,
some Republicans would have criticized
him is if they're not already criticizing
the shit out of him.
Like if you were to have a president,
Ron Paul behind that desk or a president,
uh,
Gary Johnson or President Joe
Rogan, anybody, uh, you'd be,
you'd be handed that and you'd say,
no thanks.
I'm going to veto this until
this shit is out of there.
And if the Republicans
had an issue with it,
you would've gone to the press and said,
look,
this section cannot be signed into law.
I'm not holding them.
When they say like, don't hate
the player, hate the game.
You should also maybe hate the player a
little bit cause he fucking signed it.
It would not exist without his signature.
So for people to totally ignore the
Obama involvement in this is I think
dishonest.
So how,
how is it possible that so many people
could agree with this and want to sign it?
How was that possible that I could got
get to that point where they would draft
something where they would
behind closed doors, that section, I
think it was done behind closed doors.
So it's not like they pulled the American
people in on a episode of American
idol.
It was like we got 85% response saying
we need to imprison you thought trial.
It's like a couple of old dudes,
Senator Mccain and Senator Carl Levin
decided that this is what America needs
and then before you know it,
this is what American needs.
I feel like they like gave Obama like
the opportunity to try to save face by
like saying he was going to
veto it and like how could,
how now could you like look at it and
think that he ever had any intention of
doing that?
Right.
It will still have mental gymnastics.
People are like, oh, but he's, you know,
he's doesn't want it that Dah Dah, Dah.
He's just the benign brand of the empire.
I mean that's really what I'm online.
Why would he be fighting
against Mitt Romney Spotify
playlist? That's basically
what it is, is the drone king.
So do you think that we got tricked
into thinking that Obama was something
different by just what he looked like
and the fact that he didn't have much
history to go back on and you know,
we just, idealistically I was like,
well this is the guy.
He's young. The pressure.
Yeah, it was the pressure valve from
Bush. People were like, yeah, fuck yeah,
like African American president.
And he's like, has awesome rhetoric.
But if you really analyze what he was
saying he was promoting, you know,
expanding the war in Afghanistan.
I mean he really, but yeah,
I sold a fucking billion dollar
ad campaign. Hope and change, Bro.
You also like to change
and some of the campaigns,
there's one in 2000 wouldn't want that.
Yeah. And in 2007, he said, uh,
if even one Arab American is the Tange
without a trial that affects my liberties.
And uh, like you can pull up that video
where he says that and you're like,
what about the NDA?
Like now you're,
what do they do to them when they get
them an office that gets them to behave
like this? Is there something or are they
just all full of shit? Is it they're,
they're all full of shit and
by the time they get there,
it's just they've been so good at being
full of shit for so long and they've
kept the record clean and they, they're
going to pull off the big position.
Is that it?
I don't think the parties would promote
a candidate that they didn't think it
would eventually fall in line.
Well,
it's not even a party is its banks.
I mean Goldman Sachs was the
top donor to Obama's campaign.
He's now that they're not at the top donor
to Romney's campaign. So I mean it's,
it's all just a favor doubt
though.
Do you think that they get and they say,
listen dude,
you got to just do what we say and if you
do what we say we're going to keep you
moving along. But if you don't do what
we say, you know it's over. Cause that,
is that like a real
conversation they have.
I don't think there's like a smoky
room went dude saying like Yo,
here's the fucking JFK real,
you know,
video of JFK getting assassinate. I just
think it's the, the corporate machine.
I mean you know what you have to do,
you know the game you have to play in
order to put Nigga shit pass and fucking
hold your head up.
But they just like guarantee.
I mean they just trust him to
keep going along those lines.
It seems kind of crazy to me.
It seems kind of crazy that you can
see as much of what's wrong with the
government.
That's Obama must be able to see it
must go to save the horrors of the war.
He's a smart guy. I mean, he's
not an old fucked up dude.
He's a guy that's in touch.
He's gotta be paying attention.
He's gotta be looking at
these suicide numbers.
He's got to be looking at
this horrific situation,
this saber rattling for
going to war with Iran. Him.
He has to be looking at this in Har. I
think part of it is bad advisors. I mean,
look at who he's surrounded by. These
aren't, these aren't new young people.
These are like the same people.
There are the establishment.
A lot of these people,
so maybe he's so insulated like he used
to talk about like I don't want to wind
up in a bubble and now he's most
definitely in a bubble. He goes on,
if you were to go on Msnbc,
they would just kiss his ass for 30
minutes and not mention NDA wants as the
idea of a president.
Ridiculous.
Do we need to abandon it because
it seems ridiculous to me.
It seems like one guy representing the
entire country is a silly monkey thing.
It's a silly alpha male. She'll
be a bunch of jet eyes, you know,
a bunch of smart people all sitting around
in a circle, kind of like 20 people.
A bunch of dudes that have done the cave
as a bunch of people who've done that
Dave Asprey brain thing. Yeah. That
is what congress is supposed to be,
but it's not,
they're acting outside of
their mandate as a government.
Like a lot of the things that they're
doing right now, there's really no,
like it's everything that they're doing,
it's like unconstitutional and we're
just so used to like putting up with it.
It's hard to call them.
There's so many,
and we're getting like flooded with
these bills that are obviously,
they're all unconstitutional and every
once in a while they slipped one through
it. It's all the idea behind it is
what's completely UNAMERICAN, you know?
Uh, we, we have this idea of
what, you know, what America's
supposed to stand for.
At least we used to, that that idea is
getting eroded, eroded more and more.
You pay attention to what's
really going on in the world.
It's a sad time to be alive
in that sense that it's,
we have so much going for us where we're
so technologically advanced were so we
were able to communicate with each other
and exchange information in ways that
have never been possible before
for any human being ever.
And yet we're still
living like fucking crazy.
Barbarians were still launching
rockets and to villagers,
I mean these double tap drones,
the fact that we're not there and we
don't see it doesn't mean that what you're
doing isn't fucking terrifying.
Horrific murderer, shit,
feminism to double tap,
oh, it's a double tap.
What that means is they shoot the drones
into the building and then they come
back like 20 minutes later and shoot
again because people have gathered up to
get rid of the,
the sick people in the target mourners
and people who are like combating the
sick and wounded and drones have a 2%
success rate to fucking percent success
rate. So that kind of deterred underminded
that whole logic like drones or the
strategic,
they're surgically precise now.
They're not at all 2% are think
one in 47 something like that.
End Up on the wrong dudes excel
spreadsheet, a Predator drone headed.
But how crazy is that idea that you can
murder 47 people as long as you get the
one right guy. And that's,
that's, and by the way,
thousands of people died like this. The
right guy. Like who is this fucking guy?
We haven't put him on trial. Fuck. Are
these people that were killing anyway,
relabeled the term militant basically
defined it to include just any,
anyone of that could be of age.
They're so low Custer to be like
part of like one of these groups.
They're shooting fucking
rockets from the sky in robots.
That is the most ridiculous shit ever.
They're fighting pre crime. They're like,
these people look suspicious. They're
definitely doing some militant like, shit,
let's just get rid of all of them.
You know?
It's a weird way to turn
a human into a number.
It's just bizarre that because we
don't see it within a footage of it,
we're not there. What's happening? It's
not happening over here. We're just like,
oh yeah,
we use drones and it's so relaxed or
opinion on is that Obama can make jokes
about it.
Like remember when he does,
he was joking about dating his daughters
and he said, I've got two words for you.
Predator drone. That'd be funny if
he didn't actually have mean. Yeah.
It'd be funny if thousands
of people hadn't died already
because of these things.
A lot of them, most of them innocent.
I mean, and he's joking about it.
Like what kind of weird disconnect is
that I give her if you're just a regular
dude and people would say, oh, you're
being sensitive. It's just a joke.
That's a crazy thing to joke about.
You know?
That's like Lizzie Borden joking about
access. You know, it's a little touchy.
That's a weird joke. Zero transparency
with those types of kills too. I mean,
you don't know who you hit. It's hard to
get. Got to move up to the microphone.
Sorry, I want to talk. Yeah,
I was saying like there's zero
transparency involved with that type of
technology.
There's no way for us to like confirm
who we killed or who was down there and
every organization help her number.
We don't go back to help them. Sorry.
We had to kill this one dude.
I started with fucked up
everybody and blew up your babies,
but we had to get this one dude.
Now we're going to help, you know,
there's no help.
They're just robots from the Scottish
shoot rockets and they call the rockets
hell fire missiles. Like, wow.
How crazy is this? A domestic drone thing?
The thing that scares me the most of,
of course, aside from the spine grid
that's going to be surveilling all of us.
Um, you can, you can hijack these rounds.
So people who are just hackers can just
hijack these fucking domestic drones and
use them as like,
that to me is fucking terrifying.
Crazy hacker can hijack the drone and
tell it the slim knew his girlfriend's
apartment.
Exactly.
That's going to happen. I
mean, that Shit's real. Yeah,
right. No kidding. How Sad.
How sad is it that our technology's
evolving and exponentially growing by the
second yet were stunted consciously.
Our F our evolutionary consciousness is
stunt into these archaic paradigms that
just are just mechanisms of control,
social control, fucking religion,
political ideology. It's like, dude,
we are applying to a system that does
not like we are living in a system that
does not apply to Myron society anymore.
It's strange how it just sort
of snuck up on us too. You know?
It's strange how there was like
this disdain for Nixon likes.
He sort of represented a,
an unsavory dishonest character.
And then,
you know,
Gerald Ford was kind of bumbling and
then Ronald Reagan was loved and hated at
the same time and now people go
completely gotten loony on who,
who he was and what he stands for.
And then it goes from there too.
It starts getting a little shady
with Herbert Walker Bush goals,
shady with the fucking former president
of CIA running a government with what's
going on. How's that guy? The
President? He was a little weird.
And then it goes from that to
Clinton. Oh, we're back. Look at this.
We got this guy, you know,
this guy, smart as fuck. He's,
he's a brilliant man and he says that
he's so such a charismatic speaker and we
have prosperity,
economic prosperity while he's in office.
So there's a little thing,
social disturbances from him getting
caught in affairs and stuff like that,
but all in all a good run.
And then the shit fucking hits the skids.
And then our entire view of what being
American changes on September 11th from
then on,
it goes from anger to confusion too.
You feel like you got tricked.
It goes from anger.
That American was attacked to confusion
as to why we going over there.
Two years later,
we're still there and it doesn't make
any sense and it has nothing to do with
September 11th and you're like,
wow, what the fuck? What happened
to almost accurate,
what's the word I'm looking into?
Just the best system that we
have now. It's just like, well,
he's better than Romney.
What's so crazy about the nine 11
situation when you think about it? Uh,
I interviewed this guy,
David Brin,
who wrote a book about
like transparent societies.
And on one of the pages of his
book, he was like, let's just,
this is years before nine 11 he's like,
just as a hypothetical,
let's imagine that some terrorist,
some terrorists,
a blow up the World Trade Center,
take down the twin towers.
What would the government do in
response with the federal government do?
And he basically outlines the
fucking Patriot Act. He's like,
this is what they would do and
this is what it would devolve into.
And then that actually happened and
this guy has the only solution I've ever
heard.
I don't know if it would actually work
because there are a lot of impediments to
this working, but the solution is
we can't turn off the surveillance.
We can't turn off the
technological progress.
What we can do though is use it
against the gut, not it against, but
make it a two way street.
Like instead of surveillance,
he calls it suveillance where you're just
walked. Everybody's watching everyone.
So if we were going to have trap wire and
surveillance cameras and all this shit,
fine.
But then we want to also be able to look
in there and if it's supposed to be to
keep us safe, why isn't more people a
good thing? Why isn't crowdsourcing this?
Why isn't that good?
I think eventually it's inevitable that
we're going to get to a position just
technologically speaking and where
everyone's going to be accessible to
everybody. Yeah. No,
it seems like that's what the
obvious trend is. I mean, it's gone.
Whatever we are,
whatever new technologies are created,
they're not enhancing privacy.
The new technologies are almost
always enhancing connectivity there.
Everybody's able to access
each other easier and quicker,
and Tumbler and Facebook days of your life
will be on Netflix where you could go,
I want Joe Rogan Thursday from
three o'clock to four o'clock
what's he doing? Yeah. No
people like, Oh my God,
I love watching your life
watching streaming. Nice, Bro.
Well, they're going to get crazier
than that Google thing. Whatever it is.
I can literally watch you like pissing
into a urinal and then put that up on
youtube and like that.
Yeah, for sure. Absolutely.
It's like you could call it the piste
diaries every night. We know. Yeah.
You only turn it on when you go into the
cam and he just, this is me pan again.
It's 1132 more hundred gins and uh,
Phillip kind of a bitch and people were
thinking of doing blokes to keep coming
to here, but I'm just being, it would
be like the popular one. Like wow,
that guy's really honest about his pen.
I like following him that being
glasses are going to be so awful.
The being glasses,
he's just going to be doing gps.
They're just going to shoot it
into your ivy billion cameras.
I'm going to watch everything
that goes on inside and outside.
He'll come through your skin RFID chips
in their student Ids and like punishing
them, monitoring their
bathroom time. Right.
Well your story ideas that they want
to be able to find kids, you know,
at least these are people that are,
you know,
under 18 and they have to be looked after
and there's safety considerations and
it's not like we're
making them wear a chip,
like inside their skin or anything crazy.
But that's always been there and I'm like,
why now do we like,
is it more dangerous to go to school now
than it used to be like somebody got a
contract to make these
chips and put them into you.
What parents are looking for is a good,
good guidance in school and good teachers
and safety that's still looking for
that.
I'm not necessarily sure that they're
looking for these ra fid chips because you
know those things are kind of sketchy.
Those chips,
you can get information from them and
that's one of the reasons why they never
did an episode on mythbusters spout it,
you know,
I said that it's one that was the one
episode where mythbusters was told they're
not going to cover that issue.
Yeah. So many, so many companies use
RFID. The technology is everywhere.
Well, the technology is not
secure. It can be tapping
of them. Yeah, you can
easily hack, but you know,
you were saying earlier about the people
in the government, how they've been around
for a long time. It's not even that.
I mean all these people like
Kissinger, even Madeline, all right,
all these corporate heads,
defense contractors,
they all sit on boards of these
think tanks that right our bills now,
like no one fucking
right to bills anymore.
No Congress or the Senate passed too fast.
We've actually written,
one was changed in eight hours.
It was like changed overnight.
That was way more draconian and then
everyone just voted for it because they
were in the fucking post nine 11
fervor and they're like, yeah dude,
we don't want to be unpatriotic.
It's amazing how gangster it was,
how they just ran in and immediately
started doing shit like that.
But it really,
it's such fueled
the, the deep end
conspiracy dudes, you know,
we're obviously talking
and conspiracy here.
There's someone for sure is conspiring
to control the government and there they
don't want it to just strictly be the
will of the people. That's pretty clear.
And the,
the idea that we're going to do these
things in other countries and the other,
we're going to do it for, you
know, national defense reasons.
Those also seem to be, it seems,
it seems pretty obvious. Tom's,
anybody's paying attention to,
that's not really the case.
So how long can you do that?
How long can you run a game like that?
How long do you think that
they can keep doing that?
It's melted down in Europe as we speak.
Uh, you're seeing the people there,
they're unhappy about slightly
different things. Mostly economic,
but it seems like here,
no matter how many rights you take away
and how obvious in your face it is,
most people just go along with it.
Yeah. And until they feel it, I mean,
right now you can keep people at bay until
they're fucking feeling it. You know,
who says like making us more pro,
like the people more prosperous
is a benefit to them anyway.
Like sometimes maybe it's more
beneficial for our economy
collapse.
Yeah.
But a lot of people have to agree with
the way things are going in order to keep
something like this going on.
I mean at somewhere along the
line in the chain of command,
there has to be people that
are questioning the direction
that this is all going.
Cause I don't believe that everybody that
gets involved with government is evil.
I think that's crazy.
I think a lot of people that get involved
in government are good people and they
want to actually help.
I think once they get in there and they
see that fucking Barb wire quagmire that
it is just a fucking,
just a massive corruption.
And I think then, you know,
get becomes distant heartening.
And oftentimes in life you kind of
change what you stand for or change what
you're there for and just sort of
settle into the groove. You know,
maybe you buy a boat,
you know,
and you got to pay your boat so
you keep your fucking mouth shot.
Well it's like these people at the
top half to see the collapse coming.
They have to see that
global capitalism and,
and kind of the predatory shit that we're
doing is not sustainable. I mean we're,
we're focusing on a
model of endless growth.
I mean that that can't sustain itself.
So these people have to fucking see that.
Well they, they do and yet
they don't cause they do.
And yet they feel like, well,
we'll just adjust along the way
and keep this pitch. Roland,
it's not that you can ride the car forever
without changing the tires. It's like,
no, no, no, no, no. You're
going to get some flats.
He changed the tire and you're
back on and you keep running.
And I think that's the
attitude that's going on there.
It's like until the last
drop oil in the ground,
then we can go over to alternative versus
sustainable energy and then we'll deal
with it. Well, they, I assume
they probably figured out,
they think that someone's going to
come up with some effective form of
propulsion based on water or you know,
there's,
I mean there's been people that have
made cars that have run on water.
I mean that's already existed and
converts to hydrogen. You know,
it's complicated. But so it was
making a gasoline engine, you know,
it's just a gasoline engines had been
made for thousands of years or hundreds of
years. Has it even been a hundred years.
My dating sucks weird that we don't have
Margaret Priority put on, uh, creating
the next like energy innovation.
I know that companies are spending
a lot of money to develop that,
but you look at individuals, I don't
know a single person who's like, it's,
I don't know,
a single ambitious person who wants
to develop the replacement to oil,
but I know a lot of people who want to
develop the next a hundred million dollar
Facebook APP.
You were kind of, we think
the oil issue is, uh,
is really tricky because there's
debatable science that shows that oil,
uh, grows back in some areas,
you know, and if it does,
it takes a long time and no one's
telling us how much is actually left.
There's like real,
it's a real questionable information
when it comes to how much of a supply has
left.
The real question is though,
do you just suck it all out full blast
until it runs dry and when it runs dry we
will see fucking havoc?
Or is this communicated
to the powers that be,
is there any sort of preparation
put in place with, you know,
a harnessing resources,
getting universities involved,
bringing in scientific guys and saying,
look, we've got to fucking do something.
We had to do it now either we have to
figure out some sort of solar power trains
that are gonna take everybody around you.
We're going to have to do something.
Well, he was saying that like this
morning we were taught, we were taught,
we had this almost exact same conversation
last night and he was talking about
how,
um,
some of like the economic control is so
intertwined with our need for oil that
it's difficult at this point
to just transition over.
Like the people that have control
over the way our economy fluctuates.
Um, whatever control they can have, the
dollar would be garbage. Yeah. Without,
it's linked to oil. Right. But we're not
based on gold anymore. We're based on oil,
but it felt Boyle is a
finite resource if it,
but if it only has 30 years of full,
full boat, I mean 30 years at this rate,
which by the way,
even though the oil is
consumed less by cars today,
there's more cars today. So even though
they get better miles to the gallon,
there's more of them and it takes oil to
make these fucking things and it's like
we're never going to stop making cars.
People are gonna always want a new car
and people were always going to try to
afford a car and they're going to get a
car and then at a certain point in time
you're going to run out. And if
they just run out, if it just would,
would they be wise enough to like
have any preparation in place?
You would fucking hope. So that's
the, that's the real question.
It's like when you see shit like the
Patriot Act being passed and then you see
the Nda being passed, you see
these, this crunched down lately,
you see all this buildup in the military.
They
should be, that's their idea of the
preparation. That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm worried.
What I'm saying is when I'm looking at it,
I'm looking at, if you look at the
possibility that oil is a finite resource,
that's what they say.
I'm too dumb to understand it.
I don't know who's right or who's wrong.
There's a book called black
gold stranglehold where
some guy tries to claim that
the oil oil is actually made.
It's a process of the earth.
I mean it's, it's some
sort of fossil fuel, right?
It's something that's
created by the earth,
but it takes like millions of
millions and pressed carbon mattered.
Millions magic. How
much is there? You know,
I mean they're talking about going into
Alaska and pulling it out and apparently
it's like super difficult to do that
cause it's a different kind of oil, right?
Like shale oil. It's oil, it's in rock.
It's in the oil company's interest to do,
uh, to exaggerate their
holdings. Like, Oh yeah, this,
this plot right here has 100 billion,
whatever.
I'll use barrels beneath the
soil or beneath the ground.
Who knows if it actually does, cause
it's your own proprietary calculation.
How do they calculate it? I have
no idea, but if you look up,
you think about it like which
sounds better to share holders.
We might have a billion,
a billion barrels or we have 100 billion
barrels and who's going to challenge
that?
There's,
I don't know of any like did that
would be dependent analysis group.
It does that confusing as fuck do you,
could you imagine the day the oil runs
out you want to talk about a horrific
symbiotic connection that we have.
We have like as a side,
the only way you can make this
work at all is if you have oil,
the jets that fly people
across the country for Fedex
envelopes and anything you
want to get done over night and everything
that you have that's made out of
plastic.
Almost all of that shit.
It comes from oil and if we really are
going to pull that stuff out of the
ground like that and we really are just
going to get it full blast until the
wheels fall off.
That could be what they're preparing for.
If they know that there's only a
few years less to the left of this,
that could be what they're preparing
for and that's a terrifying idea.
It's a terrifying idea because I
don't know what the alternative is.
If I was in charge and I knew that the
fucking wheels are going to fall off and
there was nothing we could do and people
are going to starve and go fucking fond,
Zombie in the street is
going to be no more oil.
I don't know what I would do either.
I don't know what I would do. Yeah.
These people are really not looking past
their bottom line every year after year.
I mean they have to be seen.
How many people would know if there
was only 20 years left of oil,
how many people would know? I mean, how
many people would really be aware of that?
It is pretty common knowledge
that we have. I mean,
oil is not,
oil is not a fucking infinite.
I mean that we'll know by the price
like as soon as it became more rare,
but they can, they can totally
bullshit that to you. Right.
How will you know how much oil they
really have and why would they tell you?
I mean,
I would think that if they,
if they did tell you it would be worse
because then people would go crazy. Now,
you know,
the inevitable would happen.
Now it's easier for them to do
that because the price of oil now,
like the way it's speculated
on like it's way over priced.
So they could actually,
as it becomes more expensive for them,
they can hold it at that
price for quite a while before
they end up having a short,
I mean it would just,
their profits would go down a little bit.
But what he's talking about oil, well,
what I mean is like as
we go less and less oil,
like they've speculated the price
of oil, it's a lot higher. You know,
it'd be like $100 dollars a barrel when
it's really only like 60 so even if they
started to run out,
they can maintain the illusion
that it's holding it $100 a barrel
for so, and we wouldn't know until
it was almost too late. Well,
it'd be too late anyway because they told
you that we have 10 years left of oil.
You have 10 years left or then then
it's over. It's too late already. Yeah,
because 10 years, 10 years tops, not
enough time, none of bio. By the way,
people are going to go straight crazy.
If you pick people,
if people found out that there's 10
years left to the oil right away,
people would fucking
start committing suicide.
They wouldn't be able to deal
with it and we'll go crazy
taking the oil out of the ground
and look what it does at Damn.
It just destroys everything and we have
sustainable alternative resources that
we can start investing it.
I mean, there are options.
It's not like we're looking at me
like what the fuck are we going to do?
We don't hold on.
Well, you got to not talk over
each other a little bit. Oh, sorry.
The podcast things a little bit different
than a regular conversation and it
seems normal, but when we're
both doing that at the same time,
it's going to be a problem.
People fall off ellipticals that way.
They go down that way. Um, what were you
saying? Uh, I don't remember. Oh, sorry.
Um, it's, I don't know.
[inaudible] our whole scene in this
country is very confusing, but that's not,
not in the, uh, not the
most confusing aspect of it.
The global warming aspect
is terrifying to have.
How many people want to
put their head in the sand?
That there's not something going on
with the climate that could potentially
damage everything? There's this weird
conservative thing where they go,
I like a guy in my Jujitsu
class the other day.
This guy is marine guy.
He's a nice guy,
but he's like one of those fucking gung
dude's and someone is talking about
global warming,
about watching something and he's like
global warming's a natural process.
And I go, what are you a fucking scientist
or something? So it was a tornado.
The can't get a good thing, but how do you
know? How do you, how does anybody know?
I mean, how the fuck could
anybody be a 26 year old guy?
Especially be so confident that you,
you can say,
you know what changes the
fucking temperature of the earth.
Which by the way changes radically
over a period of a thousand years.
Cause the point where there's places
where you used to be able to live and
nothing can live in them
now like Antarctica at one
point in time was nice and
juicy and green and had rivers
and stuff. Yeah. Not Anymore.
An asteroid is a natural process.
Awesome. Fuck yeah. I mean, so if, if,
even if it's naturally cause,
which I don't really believe for whatever
reason the earth is getting hotter and
colder, it's getting more extreme. So we,
you just start thinking
about how do we fix that?
Do we put shit up in the sky to it is
natural. It is natural. I mean the,
the natural d poisoning of the environment
is a byproduct of the human being.
And it's also cows.
Cows fucking global,
warm that shit up at places with
their dirty farts. Delicious.
You love all the burden's on us.
Like calculate your carbon footprint guys.
And you're like,
what are you gonna fucking do about the
methane gas that you're admitting from
all of these slaughterhouses? I mean,
that's like 20 of all the initial
notes right there. Or just consumer
of the largest polluting the world.
My folks used to live in Pennsylvania
when I used to drive to visit them.
I had to go through an hour and
a half of this horrific smell.
And it was these farms in Ohio,
the whole state of Ohio. Ooh,
it's so bad. It's like coming in the
events of the car. Terrific. It's just,
it's shit and dead animals.
That's what you're smelling.
You smelling shit and rot. Yeah. Farts.
Climate change is somehow a partisan
issue. Like how did that happen?
Like I don't understand why it's
a conservative talking point.
If you listen to conservative
radio, they're constantly
mock liberals, liberals,
these lives, these lives in their global
warming fee. It's unnatural process.
There's data or scientific and they have
this sort of no nonsense way about you
that makes you,
it's a very aggressive ideology.
So it makes you want to be on their side,
you know?
So it's sort of bullies you in a gold
egg. It's a globe. It's a normal process.
Meanwhile you don't even know what the
fuck you're talking about. Like a guy.
This guy interjected into this other
people's conversation. I was involved,
I was sitting on the sidelines
and he just, he just,
he walked up and they were talking and
he just interjected this conservative
talking point. It's like that's it's
fastened. Dropped it. He's like boom,
I'm out.
Cause they do it.
Like David's whole point is like who
cares if it's a natural process or not?
Like shouldn't we be doing
something about it? Most certainly.
But it is a natural process because
people are cons. There's a good,
there's a good graphic.
Every time I fucking see somebody throw
a cigarette out the window, I'm like,
why is that so easy for you to do?
Why is it so easy for you to just,
let's just make shit worse. Why is it so
easy? Right? Because we have a disconnect.
Human beings or there's something
missing in the way the human society is
currently run because it's all about the
end, the line. It's all about getting,
getting some awesome property,
you know, gathering up your toys,
living a good life, putting your kids
in a good school. That's like the, the,
the bottom end line.
And along the way there's,
there's so little emphasis
on enjoying the moment.
There's so little emphasis on what
you could actually be doing it,
how you could be feeling,
how you could be enjoying this life and
how it is finite and it really doesn't
mean you have to fuck find
out and concentrate on what
makes you happy and how
many people get to do that.
This is a small fraction of the people
that are traveling with us on the
highways and driving with
us on the streets and that
you run into every day that
are actually happy
people. It's a tiny, tiny,
tiny number because they're tricked
into this country shitty world.
There's tricky fucking goofy world where
there's a thing called the federal bank
that's not really federal and it has
control over all the money and it's not
based on anything. And the money's
not really based on anything anymore.
It used to be based on gold,
but now it's just kind of confidence.
Like you grow up with this shitty
fucking system and it's so disheartening.
It's so hard for people that have to pay
taxes to this system and have to spend
into this system. It's so hard for them
to just keep doing it and be happy.
You know?
Even if you have a good job that you
enjoy and you can't afford to live where
you live because you have to pay
too much taxes. That's maddening.
That drives people crazy.
Like you can't live in a nice neighborhood
and you have to live in a little bit
of a Shitty your neighborhood because
you've got to pay 40% of the government.
Can you imagine if, if society rewarded
you for creation instead of like,
I mean all the, like the, the,
the smartest people in this country
are working to for destruction. I mean,
how did like build bombs and kill people?
It's like,
what if we rewarded rewarded
people and creativity?
How to scam you with ads on
Facebook, all that. Yeah,
the Predator drone or scam you
out of money. It's amazing.
We're just stunting our potential so much
for human growth and our consciousness.
We're on the cusp of greatness and there's
just a couple of psychopaths sort of
like cock blocking us,
Paul. It's a, there's a whole
culture of the uninvolved unevolved.
There's a a culture of people that still
have this fucking buck Rogers view of
the world. It's not, it's not a
small amount. It's a lot of people.
It's people that haven't had
any psychedelic experiences.
It's people that are from really dumb
environments than the in they're, they're,
they're prone to imitating
their atmosphere and the
atmosphere is filled with
idiots and it's not a small number. It's
a big number. Unfortunately, this more,
almost 50% of this country believes that
the earth is less than 10,000 years old
based on scripture.
Almost 50% of the country.
That's more than a hundred million people.
That's craziness. Let's sad it has in.
It isn't. It's fascinating and it's,
it, it's, it's, it's weird. You know,
it's like if you see those videos of
people like that go to these strange rain
forests and they, they find this
tribe that's never seen people before,
they catch it on camera, cause some
fucking weirdness to it, right?
When you see like, wow, you
know, these poor people, they're,
they're living in here with leaves on
our dicks and jumping from tree to tree
and then you look at
la.
Yeah.
You look at, you look at our
society, you look at our,
our craziness and you
somewhere along the line,
I think everybody has to conclude that
no one really is in control of this
fucking thing.
It runs on momentum and whether
it's good momentum or bad momentum,
it runs on momentum.
That's really important when you're
looking at the, looking at the election,
you see like the bullshit.
It propagates because of momentum.
Some people who are really anti Romney,
you're trying to push this sense
Sada story, however it's pronounced.
It's his company that he used to
invest in that outsource American jobs.
The Chinese workers.
I think that's like that's like
the cliff notes version and uh,
they're trying to make this a huge issue
so they're just like blowing up Twitter
feeds with it and asking journalists
to cover it and the facts are that it's
really not that big an issue.
I'm not saying this is some kind of like
Republican shill. I'm an independent,
it's just like it's clearly
not a big fucking issue.
He used to invest a small amount of money
in this company and like it'd be like
if I own shares of Microsoft five years
ago and then you came up to me and
you're like, dude, the Zune
sucks. Why do I care about that?
I don't own any shares of this company.
And like if I did it was a small share.
And how is that the most important
thing happening now when you
should be going after maybe
like some of his beliefs,
sort of his beliefs on the war,
on drugs continuing that is belief
something we need to increase our defense
budget.
I think those are more important issues
than some fucking obscure company that
he might have invested in a while ago.
It's weird that Mormons,
generally speaking,
I like super nice guys.
Like I've met a lot of Mormons and one
of the things about them is they're like
almost like to a man changeovers friendly,
gentle,
gentle lovers.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Like they seem to be like sort of a
peaceful religion. Very nice. But it's,
I think it's hostile to think that you
have to convert other people to your
belief system. Well, it's nice to be
like in a tie and be friendly to people,
but if your underlying thing is these
people are idiots because they don't
believe what I believe. Well it's
a cult. I mean, don't get me wrong,
I'm just saying it's a cult that
makes nice people. If the outcomes,
it's a cult and, and, and, and even if
you know you, you want to diverge from,
you know, that you want to say all
religions are called, well maybe,
but here's when they're clearly calls.
When you know the guy who wrote it. Yeah.
It's like 50 years ago.
His fucking name is Joseph Smith
in 1820 really liked women.
So that's why you get the multiple wives.
That's by the way,
why Mitt Romney's families from Mexico,
Mitt Romney's family comes from I
fucking religious compound in Mexico.
They separated from the United States
because they wanted to fuck more bitches.
That shows leadership leadership,
having your own compound in Mexico.
That's dope as fuck, dude. I just
moved there because he want 20 wives.
They were like, you can't have 20
wives. He was like, oh bitch, I can,
I'll just got to go here.
And when they did it too,
it was in the 18 hundreds and you know,
there was no cars yet.
So America wasn't quite
as awesome as it is now.
There wasn't really that much of a
difference between living in Mexico and
living in Texas. You know, he just
went over there, okay, now I can do it.
Let's just buy some land here. It's cheap.
We'll fucking make a bad ass compound.
They outsource themselves. So that's
why midst dad could never be president.
And His dad wanted to be president, but
he was born in Mexico. Shazamm sorry.
Isn't that crazy?
He mean he's a full on nutter.
I mean he's not just from a cult.
He's from the branch that left the
country because they wanted to continue
their, their multiple wife practice.
You can have multiple wives,
but you can't marry a gay person. That's
bad. God doesn't want it. I'm old.
Marriage is next.
Medical marijuana don't believe in it.
I believe I'm just turned up.
Can I play devil's advocate
on the door on me since he,
since we actually have a record of
what he did when he was governor of
Massachusetts, we see that he
did not try to, for example, uh,
in prison or execute women who
use like the morning after pill.
He said that he didn't do
this shit. You know, like,
so like some of the fantasies coming
from certain elements of the left. Uh,
and I hate to use terms
like the left and the right,
cause I'm totally against that stuff.
But these fantasies,
it's like he was governor,
he was a powerful guy. He
didn't do any of that shit.
He was fairly moderate.
You can attack him for being
a kind of a heartless person,
but he is not nearly as extreme
as I think, as people think.
And as he's portraying himself to be.
Well,
I think he's very flexible
and I think he's, it's what's
really important for guys like Mitt Romney
has to be in power and Massachusetts
is a very liberal state.
I grew up in Massachusetts.
You can't get by on just total
strict Republican, you know,
rhetoric in Massachusetts,
it's not going to work.
So he sort of went with the flow
of the thing. That's what I think.
And I think he's a,
that's the most dangerous thing about
him is that he doesn't seem to have like
real strong opinions on things. I mean,
he seems to know how to make money with,
you know, I don't understand
what they do. I mean,
I've tried to look into like what's
supposed to be so evil about Bain capital,
but it's, to me it's, it's numbers
nonsense. It's all craziness.
I read the Matt Taibbi
article in Rolling Stone,
which is a another mind fucking
sort of a view where you're like,
why do you make money doing watts?
Like I need to do it.
And then they move it from here
and then they give them loans.
He never pay it back and like walked off.
Fuck Mitt Romney said he harvests
business businesses for profit.
Sounds like ma the matrix
and harvesting human being.
But do you know the bank capital?
Bain capital is actually integral
into a pushing Monsanto into biotech.
So Bain capital.
Yeah,
Mitt Romney got $1 million from the ex
CEO of Monsanto when he was starting off
at Bain capital and he got pushed into,
you know,
he's very tight with Monsanto.
So as Obama they all are,
it's so creepy when you find that
the history of Monsanto, you know,
everybody thinks about, Oh man, these
genetically modified foods are dangerous.
How about AZT? How about
fucking, how about Agent Orange?
The chemo with Agent Orange,
that company making your DHT
grains that are in your cereal.
It's crazy to his cancer
medication. Ddt and DDT, they made
Agent Orange and here they
are making a call on hollow.
How's about how a lot of player,
I fucking poison the shadow Alyse then
Alabama for like decades and knew about
it and everyone's like dying and they're
like, oh yeah, our bad. Sorry about that.
Was it with the use PCBs just dumping
the shit in the water and everyone's like
retarded now. Whoa. Why would they dump
it in the water? Just because they could,
they had it and it was there and
that's how they got rid of it. Wow.
Zero regulation.
It's a, the, the Indian farmer things,
the scariest thing when you feel God,
hundreds of thousands of Indian farmers
have committed suicide is does it,
how would,
how are they connected to Monsanto by
choice or is it like they have no choice
where to buy their seeds?
Um, they are, yeah,
they're being forced. Well,
one of our main thing and the government
is forcing Monsanto seeds on them and
so they're burning them
and people are just like,
why would poor people burn food?
And you're like,
because they'd get it like they don't
mean it's crazy like owning non-regulated
seeds or something like that.
Like if you,
you have to get your
seeds from a certain way,
the most sinister shit out there and
also creates mono cropping and destroys
local agriculture.
If there is a god,
a seed is clearly designed to be something
that should not be regulated or bad
cause it drops through the fucking tree.
You know, like it creates more of an eat.
Some of them,
it creates more of them.
Like it's not something that's
supposed to be a Somby competitive
products. We're making Zombie plants
that can't make babies, you know,
so you have to keep buying
seats from these fucking, this,
this evil group of people that's planning,
grading super worms and shit though.
So it's like not even going
to work anymore and that's
what's going to be really
scary about it. The idea of, of doing
it for profit too. It's just so,
it's so crazy how much
money can make doing that.
And they're getting away with it.
And now they see the study that shows
his tumors that are some rats that are
eating genetically modified corn. Creepy.
Well, you know, it's not an actual food.
There's, there's a, there's a crazy
battle going on. Ladies and gentlemen.
This is just one of the rats
get cancer from like everything,
those fucking losers.
But what about the terminates or alluded?
That's a weapon on down made a
terminator seed that destroys it.
So after one year, no, it's swear to God,
it's, it destroys itself after one yield.
You're like,
why would you even have to make that?
What are you going to use
that for such a your seeds?
So that's just the fuck over. Barch a
god thing. It's such a claim. I mean,
you're playing God, you're,
you're actually fucking with life.
And because it's a plant, we were like,
ah, it's just a plant. It's still life.
That's a living organism
and you fucked with it.
And now you're growing your own organism.
And then you wrote,
you wrote that you own this organism. I
mean, Jesus Christ, you own it. I mean,
it's like a dog. Like you know,
this is your shit. You know,
you've made little robot
seeds, the you, you now,
you now you own all these,
you seldom these people and they can
never use them again and they can't,
they don't grow.
So the whole idea behind it is insanity.
It's insane that you could
be able to patent life
where they actually outlaw collecting
rainwater too. So, you know,
you get the idea that no one's protected,
that no one's come in and
protected that and said, listen,
you cannot own life if you
can't patent life, you can't.
You can't have the genetic code for
pigs. Yeah, you want another one?
How about bottled water?
We were talking about this yesterday.
If you're to go back in time 30 years
and tell somebody, uh, 30 years from now,
you're going to have to pay $2 50 cents
out of a machine for a bottle of water
to hotel.
And on top of that,
most of our wars are going to
be fought by robots in the sky.
People at the venue are
like schizophrenia. That's
crazy. Shit. Water's free.
Just go down to the daughters
told me that even years ago,
I probably wouldn't believe
you. The water, the issue is a,
is a tough one because you know, some
people say it's just drink, tap water.
It's safe. Like Penn and teller
had a whole show about it. But no,
it's not really okay. Because there's
fluoride in it. And guess what flora?
It's poison. I mean it's a very low
level poison and the idea is that floor,
it's supposed to kill the bad things that
are on your teeth to give you cavities.
And that's,
I guess maybe that it does that,
but you really could get away without it.
You could brush your teeth
without using fluoride.
Fluoride is fucking kind of dangerous.
It's not healthy for the body.
And you know, you drink water
with fluoride in it all the time.
There's been studies that show that
it could calcify your pineal gland,
which is where Melatonin and DMT or
produced like that fluoride actually can
fuck with the chemistry of your
brain if you take in a lot of,
especially if you're drinking a lot of
tap water every day and you think about
how much flora that there could have
bathing thinking, I mean you're
already in consuming, I mean why,
why is it that we
accepted this propaganda?
We still do that somehow the fluoridation
of water supplies all across the
country is good for us. I mean
it's mass medication. It's a,
it's a byproduct of phosphate mining.
They sell it to municipalities and
we drink it. I mean it's insane.
Yeah,
and by the way,
it was one of Hitler's ideas to fluoridate
the water to keep the population
numb. Those Hitler's idea, like it
was much more fluoride I believe.
Then we use now I think,
you know,
ours is less and sinister and I think
they did it because someone tricked them
into doing it for, you know, the
idea of a dental hygiene. It's like,
we ha I had this Guy Dave Asprey on the
show yesterday and he was talking about
how bullshit,
how much bullshit is involved in the
idea of a salt of having a low salt diet
and how crazy that is.
And he was talking about how that's just
propaganda that stuck around like a no
salt diet.
How's it supposed to have plenty of salt?
My salt salt's in essential minerals.
This Guy Dave Asprey,
carry salt around with them.
He brings salt with him everywhere.
He goes like he has salt every morning.
He says it's like an essential,
like part of being a human animal.
You need it to retain water. Yeah,
everybody needs it. It's just one
of those things where you know,
you get sold some wacky bill of
goods, you know, like, remember,
do you ever remember those commercials
that they used to have where they had
doctors suggesting particular types
of cigarettes? It was a crazy,
it helps with digestion as your meal.
God.
Doctors are recommending where Shit
today in cigarettes. Well, do you, um,
what was the movie? Oh, Jay Edgar. The
J Edgar Hoover. I thought that was good.
It was good.
The Leonardo Dicaprio movie and in it
she says that the doctor prescribed him
cigarettes for his health,
like to make them more robust.
There's a prescribed cigarettes,
it was on mad men and there was actually
a movie that came out a few years ago
and like it was kind of post apocalyptic
and the people who lived there like
they would have to smoke cigarettes
cause it had medication in it and protect
them from like the like I think I've
seen that that means they're just given
them wheat. Salem Wenson must've paid a
lot for, yeah, cigarettes are cast alive.
You,
you said stuff about,
it's like you didn't really like
it because it kind of sucked.
I enjoy it as background. I put it on
when I write sometimes visually. Yeah.
It's the length that I tweet it to
you about that. What about it? Uh,
they created a fake corporate
website for Wayland,
which is the company that
backs their mission. Right.
And from atheists and on the
website there's all kinds of shit.
Like there's a fake Ted talk given in
the year 2023 or he's talking about how
like now we can create android so we
have the same power as God. Oh Shit.
And they did such a good job with the
website that you look at it and you're
totally like,
this could be Google and the next like
20 years or whatever big company happens
to be around.
I think,
you know,
I watched promethium and that's one of
the things I thought when there's like,
you know, if we're from a [inaudible],
you know, the year 2092 or whatever, what,
22 what was, what was the year? Oh yeah,
it was like seven years and it was like
90 years from now or something like that.
Whatever, whatever the fuck is spoilers.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. And uh, I,
when I was looking, I
was like, you know what,
that is really underestimating how
fucking nutty things are going to be.
Cause that doesn't even look hardly nutty.
The only thing that's nutty about that,
they can go further into space.
They'd go to sleep for a little while
and they got holograms. That ain't shit.
I think that's really underestimating.
They sort of interconnectivity that
people are going to enjoy just in the next
decade.
I think it's going to be wait crazy.
And then promethium I'm looking forward
to like a psychic version of Gmail.
It's going to be like, look,
you're going to be connected.
You're going to be connected to
people in some other weird way.
It's just the same way you are
through your phone in a wireless way.
Someone's going to figure out how to make
that something that speaks directly to
your synapsis. They're going
to make it. Yeah, absolutely.
There's gotta be something like that.
There's going to be something that
allows you either in a clinical setting,
it will probably be that way first and
then it's just going to integrate into
your life. You know? It's
Kinda got to figure out a way.
It's everyone's going to need God.
God Damn Electric toothbrush.
Everyone's going to have one.
Well, I was, I was kinda disappointed.
I don't know what you were saying
about probate this earlier,
but I'm really into that theory too,
that aliens created us and so I
was like kind of like, fuck yeah,
they have like a movie about
this. Then I was like, aw man.
It kind of just wasn't as
good as I thought it would be.
Shit version of the idea.
Such an idea
the,
yeah,
the ancient aliens theory debunked or
ancient aliens showed debunked is a
fucking amazing youtube clip where
a guy created this, his names,
well I don't want to say his name,
some it'd be, he doesn't want his name,
but he's got to come on the podcast.
Thank you. So I think he's out. Tom.
Chris. Anyway, so he debunked and
the whole, let's fucking, what am I?
So it's not like he did anything dangerous
when I'm saying Chris White. Anyways,
very nice guy.
We've been going back and forth on
Twitter and this guy was a believer at one
point in time and then just started
looking into all the different things that
they've claimed on the show and you know
that shows goofy as fuck, but it's fun.
This dude wrecked it. Aw Man.
Crushed it. It means nothing now.
It means nothing.
I mean,
it's still a lot of mystery until
like the construction methods used for
building the pyramids and moving
obelisks and stuff like that. But he,
he basically crushed them on
all of their major points.
I heard the diplomat just comes
his hair to the side so glossy.
He looks like me shaking his
head just like, fuck this.
It started off really good cause
you're like, all right, the pyramids.
Maybe this other shit in South America.
Maybe.
Then you run out of things to point the
finger at and now it's like bigfoot.
Was George Washington really influenced
by an alien visitation and it's like
you're just picking random things that
of history at this point and trying to
superimpose crazy.
We were doing Samurais.
Yeah, that's what you
need. You've gone too far.
Samurais who could have come up with
the technology to make the sword?
Could it possibly have been aliens?
Joe, have you seen Sam? Sorry yet? No.
Oh Man. He's really
fucking shit. What is it?
Have you seen Baraka or choir get
Scott to that trilogy? Dude, oh my God.
It's just a fucking, it's
just all images and, and,
and really amazing images from all
around the world. Uh, the, you know what,
what did the film's called?
Baraka and Sam. Sarah,
I feel like I'm in a cult because I'm
like telling everyone to watch and see
what it is, so I forget who directed it.
I want to say Phillip Glass at the music,
but it's just all of the world's wonders
and it's just so intense that it takes
you into the soul of people and then like
it moves to another image and then it
moves to another image. Like there's a
bunch of people climbing up mount. Yep.
Yeah, I've seen that. Yeah. Yeah.
It's incredible. It's incredible.
I just feel like I'm,
I feel like I'm tripping on mushrooms
when I watch it because it's just so
intense. Like it's just different
cultures all around the world and the,
and the juxtaposition between,
you know,
Modern Day society in ancient
cultures and how they,
they're living in the same time
and then it's just incredible.
I bet that's going to be like the first
technology when it comes to like really
tapping into another person's life.
They're going to create like a real for
us and everyone's going to get the same
real and you'll be able to put it on
cause it takes a long time to record it.
It's very difficult to process.
So it's going to be like that game.
Dragon's layer. Do Remember
the game? Dragon's layer? No,
it was the first video game and the
dragon's layer video game wasn't really a
video game.
Like you would be shown an animated thing
and then you'd have to move the lever
one way or another way to get
away or to get fucked like you,
like one or one of them doesn't happen.
Either you moved it the right way and
then they would show you a new screen.
Congratulations and you move on to the
next round or it would show you you
getting hit in the head by
a giant boulder and dying.
It was the stupidest video game ever,
but it was like really clumsy because
they couldn't quite get it yet.
Now they have full motion three d graphics
that are absolutely insane and you
play it,
it's full immersion.
I think that's what it's going to be
like the first time you get a chance to
peek into somebody else's brain.
They're just gonna take a whole just
segment of people from all over the world
and make it into the
one dope ass mix tape,
put it on and get to
like live changing lives.
And then it's gonna move from there to
the point where we're eventually all
going to have the ability
to transmit and receive.
Just get off the bench. It's gonna be
really cool. They can record brand,
they can record dreams now. Like actually,
uh, get digitally, interpret them. Yeah.
Well they've, they've have been able
to get blurry images for dreams.
They've also been able to,
uh,
get blurry images from memory and they
think that they might be able to figure
out whether or not people are guilty or
not and whether or not by whether some
certain images exist in their memory.
If they can grab him.
I think in Grad just that means they
can probably put in images. Yeah, well,
by the way, I bet your imagination
can put those images in there as well.
And then it becomes the question
of whether or not the mat, I mean,
how much power does the
imagination have over reality?
Because a lot of people
think that, you know, well,
imagination is just what's not real.
And a reality is what Israel. Okay.
You don't want to be too
imaginative, Jimmy, but the,
the reality is that everything that real
is created because of the imagination.
The imagination is the
reason why we have tables.
That's the reason why
someone invented a rocket.
It's a reason why a computer exists.
If someone had a thinking and then it
manifested itself in the real life,
then the imagination becomes a very
different thing because then it becomes
something that you know,
through a human and through the human
touching things and moving things,
manipulating with this idea,
it can change physical reality.
So it's not just an innocuous little
thing floating in space. The imagination,
when you sit down and come up with
things and create things and actually
physically make them, it made those
fucking things. It did it through you.
Then the question becomes can it do that
to everything else as well and is it
just we do,
we look at the imagination is like,
well we can control this because
I'm a creative person and you know,
I drink a lot of coffee and then I
sit down and I do my work. Is it,
is that the case or is the imagination
like a force that moves everything in the
universe and we're just doing our little
itty bitty bitty part of it? Well, yeah,
I think the placebo effect is a prime
example of something that no one talks
about, but it's a fucking miracle. You're
like, you're mine did this. Like how come?
That's amazing.
Why don't we focus more on the fact that
the placebo effect is incredibly mind.
My hands are able to throw it away
because you thought that it was going to
reality might not necessarily
be something you'd knock on.
It might be the the tune of the way you
look at the world and your perceptions
and your expectations can literally
change what happens. That's a,
that's a hard,
you know what I mean?
It can't be 100% because
babies dying drive bys.
There's like some weird
shit that goes on there.
But then there's also the thought
like if this is a continuous cycle,
that's what so many eastern religions
believe that you will come back and a lot
of them believe you will come back until
you get it right and you'll keep living
the same life over and over again
until you do it with zero mistakes.
And you do it as an enlightened being
from the time you were a baby to the time
you leave and then you move on
to the next stage of existence.
So we're in this constant
and endless cycle.
But if there was a way to,
to know that you were going to
die and come back as a baby,
but you had to take a chance that you're
going to be a baby in a good house,
how terrifying would that fucking trip be?
You would never want to die.
He would never want to die because what
if you came up with some fucking asshole
parents? What if you came up
with some abusive environment?
What if you were born in Ethiopia and
what if you're born some shit part of the
world where you can't get out,
you're fucked.
If we had people that really believed
that the only way to ensure your Karma,
the only way to ensure you're safe
passage as a child to adulthood is to go
through this life being as loving and is
careful and as considerate as possible
and it's spreading as much
positive energy as possible.
If we really could get people to think
that that would change reality because
every baby would grow up in an
environment where people did grow up in an
environment where people love them because
they didn't want to be stuck in some
fucking shit hole in the middle
of Pakistan in a hut somewhere.
Why drones are shooting missiles over
their heads. I was thinking of Glendale,
I was thinking where the, where the
bombs hit man, where the drone son,
if we get people to believe that you
can get people to think, look the die,
that might be real. I mean, it
really, I mean if, I don't know,
I don't understand the idea of
reincarnation, but if it does exist,
people are going to be terrified if they
could prove that exist. Just that alone,
but free people the fuck out.
The fact that you just gonna keep coming
back as a person and a new life every
time. If you believe in the Dalai
Lama and what he represents, uh,
they claimed that he has the option of
just like opting out next time you opt
out of the body scanner at the
Tsa. He can just be like, I'm done.
Like I'm not going to do this.
And he doesn't want to be the Dalai Lama.
And I see that he has that choice.
Like apparently after he dies,
he can tell whoever's in charge of the,
you coming back in a body can be like,
I'm just, I'm done with this.
No more earth. He's just,
he has that option. He's,
he seems like a wonderful guy,
but he stuck it in an ideology.
He's dressed like an idiot. He's being
silly as fuck. The whole thing is silly.
It's completely silly.
This clothes thing where you have to
wear certain clothes to be, I mean you,
you have to be completely expressionless
in the way you keep your body warm.
That's nonsense. That doesn't make
any sense. If there's a real god,
he doesn't care if you wear pants,
it doesn't care if you have
a fucking ACDC tee shirt on,
he should wear whatever the fuck you want.
That's craziness.
The whole idea that you can have sex
with anybody, I'll come on, you know,
the idea that it takes over and
obsesses your life. Um, no it doesn't.
If you get your shit together stupid,
the idea that you can't have sex because
it ruins your life doesn't always ruin
your life dummy.
It's sometimes it enhances your life.
You're not living 100% full life.
So this idea that you're enlightened yet
not living, stop it. That's nonsense.
You need to go out and he'd get need
to get drunk and right now and then you
need to have a shot of whiskey and need
to go to Vegas and see what a real strip
clubs look like.
Maybe that's maybe that's a Mitt.
Romney needs just a hard weekend in Vegas.
He needs to go back to Mexico.
It goes back to Mexico and fucking camp
out with the Colton and load rifles as
they look around for kidnappers. That's
what they do. They talk up a black girl.
I think you just nailed it.
A black girl really likes mushrooms.
The lack of psychedelic experiences is
a real problem for people that are in
office. And I say that it
sounds completely ridiculous,
but I really think it's,
you need something as a,
as a human being,
they need something every now and
then the jolt you out of your walls of
perception because we get stuck. You get
stuck thinking that this makes sense.
You get stuck on a momentous
journey where you know the,
the momentum keeps pushing you along the
same path and there's no room to adjust,
especially if you're part of a
corporation and something big.
Every corporation should have a fucking
retreat every six months where they all
go to the desert together and they
all trip. They're fucking balls off.
And then they rethink their life and
then they get together and they have a
meeting on Monday. And I
go, what do you think? Well,
the fucking Lizard Guy with the tail
and the way he told me, I'm fucking up.
And uh, they showed me the future
and it's not good. We listen.
We've got to get these suicides.
People's hands. Well,
yeah, we can't be making,
making money off them that this is
fucked. You know, they would, they would,
they would realize the
error of their ways,
but instead they have a whiskey and an
ambient and they go to sleep. And the,
the drugs that we have available now,
whether it's Oxycontin,
which is readily available to anybody
that stubs their toe, you know,
all these different
drugs that are available,
they're available and they
have a numbing quality to them.
They have a quality that allows
you to not look at the big picture,
but just play your role and put your
nose down and grin and bear it, you know?
Do you know any fucking people are
on antidepressants during the day and
sleeping pills at night?
It's a staggering number.
It sends a recipe for insanity,
like some of those civic because you
walk around and don't remember where you
were. Oh yeah. That happens a lot.
I used to work at a,
a at a physician's office and he handled
mostly like injuries and every single
patient that came in there
with like a work injury,
they would get an antidepressant
because they weren't working.
So obviously they're depressed.
Um, they would get a painkiller,
they would get like
meloxicam or something,
but it was like a sedative
and an antianxiety pill.
And it was like five or six pills at,
like almost every single patient would
walk out with mass diag, you know,
just diagnosing everyone that comes
in there with anxiety and depression.
I had no idea it was such an issue
until I had a few friends that,
that got prescribed them and I saw it
like changes in their personnel and so
weirdness, you know, I saw
people that acted irrationally.
And then, uh, especially,
um,
when I was on news radio,
Phil Hartman's wife was on
Zoloft when she killed him,
she was on Zoloft and cocaine.
And apparently that is a psychotic
combination like literally makes you
psychotic.
And to the point where the family got
a settlement from Zoloft family got a
settlement because of that and
it's been shown to have, you know,
horrific effects. So I, I started looking
into it and then I found the numbers,
the numbers of people that
are on antidepressants and
they're fucking staggering.
It's staggering.
And as far as like long term studies to
see what kind of an effect that should
has on you in 2030 years,
have there been any,
I mean do they know how about
people who don't need them?
Those people are part of an ongoing
experiment. You are the data.
If you're on those pillars here,
the data that people,
20 years from now I'll be looking at,
well it's amazing every time there's
like a famous person that dies from,
from pills that are just like,
oh they don't really talk about it
wouldn't before it was like yeah,
they died of his speed ball. It's like
now this is legal heroin, legal cocaine,
legal speed, way crazier. I mean fucking
all the fentanyl patches and shit.
I mean they're just
like giving this thing.
I called my doctor wants to consult about
birth control and within five minutes
she was trying to give me an
antidepressant. I wanted to get pregnant.
Or you didn't want you to know?
No,
I just was calling just to consult about
like different kinds of birth control
and she was just like, well are you
feeling moody? And she was like,
let's talk about your like moodiness.
And she was like, I was like,
is this illegal for you to like try to
push meds on my second for the brain?
It's like if you were
oh you are a person who
like wasn't strong minded,
you would go it just because
your doctor recommended. Yeah.
America is one of only two countries
in the world that allowed direct to
consumer advertising with
pharmaceutical pills, US and
New Zealand. Random. Right.
She's my dad's a doctor and he
hates the ask your doctor about,
cause you're misleading people.
Like if you think you have a
symptom and like you're like,
oh I got to ask my doctor
about this to get it fixed.
There are a hundred other diseases that
could be causing that symptom and that's
where you go to a fucking doctor in
the first place so you can be diagnosed
properly.
But instead what happens is you go,
this must be what I have because the TV
ads so convincing you look it up on web
MD. It confirms your ex your
expectations. Yeah. This is what I have.
You go to your doctor and you're like,
here,
you know I've done the research for you
and then you're putting your doctor and
an awkward situation where if he
doesn't do it, you want them to do.
You suddenly think he's not
giving you the right care,
but you really have to rely on an expert.
It'd be like you don't see that for cars.
You don't see advertisements for like,
uh, you know you don't, you don't just
walk into a car dealership and say,
here's what's wrong with my car
and need to do this, this and this.
You tell them to check it out.
It's kind of interesting that you
can't sell cigarettes anymore.
That's the one thing.
You can't sell an ads anymore.
Can't have cigarette
commercials except there's,
remember that new one we
saw with the electronic
cigarettes? Oh yeah. It so sexy.
Let me try to find who was
Steven Bauer. No, no, no, no.
Stephen Dorff. Yeah. Oh my God. Please
pull that commercial up. Oh my goodness.
Yes they do.
It's not the nicotine.
Nicotine is actually has some
positive effects on the body.
Nicotine actually is beneficial. It
can help people with heart issues. Uh,
it helps people be more creative.
Like nicotine itself is as a drug,
as a compound. Isolated
compounds. Not Bad.
What's bad is when you smoke it and he's
smoking a cigarette form with 590 other
fucking chemicals, they're all poured
in there by your own, you know,
approved by your own loving government
just to make those cigarettes more
addictive. That's when shit gets really
bad. Make them burn a little bit better.
Yeah. Shit into it. But let's be honest,
this is kind of disturbing to watch
that because it is still nick,
Tina, and people can still get addicted
to nicotine, you know? Yeah, they can.
You're right. Yeah.
What's, watch this. This is
beautiful.
I'm Steven door.
I've been a smoker for 20 years and
I just found the smarter alternative.
Blue aesics blue lets
me enjoy smoking without
sexy years.
He's a rebel.
He's got to James that jacket on
and best of all he said the beach.
He's so cool. He's got a beach
house like we're all adults here.
Hello Ring. Oh my guys. It looks cool.
I just want to go to parties with him.
Oh Stephen Dorff.
Does it
party with him?
Yeah, that's the kind of, if like
you've met a guy and he liked it,
pulled out a cigarette and started telling
you how awesome it was like that he
would run like the house was on
fire and we just run away from him.
You who fucking dis design
that commercial commercial.
If you looked in the eyes
of blue smoke like that
actory fuck you dummy. You got to
choose. Either are selling shit.
Are you going to be an actor? You
can't be all actory. What does that,
what it was that an emotional moment for
Yale? He can considering your nest next
project on a kick that guy in the balls.
When I said that commercial,
that's insulting. Fucking
insulting commercial. You fool,
but I'm not hating us. Even a for me, if
he got paid, go for it dude. Whatever.
Just think you could have done a better
job. I think you kind of phoned it in.
I liked you in blade though,
Dude. Pretty sweet and blade.
That's saying you're a bad actor.
I'm saying that Shit's preposterous
son and take it from me.
I've done preposterous shit. You got to
know when you did it. You just did some
black and white walk and by the beach
with your fucking James Dean Jack and on
sucking on a blue robot.
Dick.
That's a blue robot. Dick. You really
need to suck on that blue robotics.
Come on man. Why? Why don't you just get
some Nicorette Gum? You look at my like,
he's fucking serious.
He's serious and he's going
to say something cool right
before he shows you that
it's blue. Yeah. This is like a scene in
a movie that's making fun of the future.
That's what it is. Johnny drama. This
is like Johnny drama. Got a commercial.
If he's acting it.
If you are watching like uh,
like one of those Arnold Schwarzenegger
movies or like the Terminator or
something like that where if they
were making fun of the future,
showing you a video of what
the future would be like,
this would be really robot fucking
cigarettes and election man and this silly
pitch is smoking them. What are you doing
dude? He's a little wrinkly forehead.
He's fucking serious problem. Leno at
a mountain, the Beach Doula surfing.
Sometimes I just move sand
holes.
I'll make trenches and make my own
rivers and they lost mode. You know,
I make like these castles and I loved
the fact that we're not going to be there
and an hour they're gone,
but they're there now.
I live for now for now
with my blue cigarettes.
I was just thinking how you were saying
that people are just generally an
unhappy because they're overworked.
They're not fucking following their true.
We'll all this shit.
I was just thinking the other day watching
the soup because it highlights the
most ridiculous reality shows that you
can't even believe our fucking on TV.
But just like the, my strange addiction,
like people who eat scotch tape and shit,
you're like, I'm sure they saw
this. They're like, what the fuck?
I was just only like first world problems.
Like can you imagine anyone
else like having that problem?
Like I can't stop eating couch upholstery.
I have a problem. How about PD?
The first world problems Hashtag
on Twitter that people, yes. Yes.
They took some of those tweets that were
popular and they super imposed them or
they didn't superimposed and they had
kids and like really poor people in Haiti.
Oh God. All right. This shit.
It's a video you can look up.
It's like Katie first world problems
and it's like, I hate how my,
my two door garage takes like 10 seconds
to open and your mother were like
starving animals in the background
and stuff and it's like,
it starts to hit home.
Like you're kind of an asshole if you
spend all day tweeting about stuff like
that.
Like it's okay to acknowledge that like
you're privileged and you have a lot of
shit that most people on earth don't have.
But a certain point,
maybe you give $20 to your favorite
charity instead of tweeting that all
afternoon. Yay. Silly Bitch. Hey Brian.
How funny was that a video
that you pulled up yesterday
and silent live video. You want to
pull it out? Should we pull it out?
It's so funny. They did a fight for, I've,
I haven't washed out and lived a long
time cause siren live went through this.
It's really went through
a spell where it was just,
I couldn't watch isn't it getting better?
I don't know.
I heard but this is fucking fantastic.
This is the first thing that I've seen
from them in years and I only saw it
because Brian was watching the computer,
but it's them making fun
of people complaining about
apple products and then the
people who answer or the Foxconn
employees. Holy Shit. Is it funny to do?
You got it.
Tyna nbc.com unfortunately,
so I'm trying to watch the
commercial right now. Oh,
you have to watch a 32nd one.
What did it, I'm trying to sell you
missiles. They did it, but yeah, yeah.
Don't be complainant bitch. You can
easily be born in Ethiopia with no feet.
Maybe we'll be,
if you can play,
maybe that mother fucker is
a medium for knowledge there.
Could you imagine if everybody that was
in a shit situation just he used to mock
people and shit situations in the
last life. If it was that cut and dry,
it was that easy to follow
where the Kardashians headed.
I feel like they're not real.
I feel like probably from another
planet and it's some sort of a,
a device they're using to gauge
our stupidity, like saying no,
it's like a robot. It's like girl,
she's like a robot fucked off in space.
That's what I think because
they've totally overestimated
or position like her,
her, uh, her physique rather, I mean her
ass is just completely out of control.
It's gotten just insane.
It is growing and it's not growing in
a natural way because their legs aren't
growing with it.
Like if she became like some crazy power
lifter and she just developed these
giant muscular thighs, this huge
ass, that would make sense. But no,
someone in youtube describe it best.
He said it looks like a diaper
filled with putting, yeah,
that's what it looks like. It looks like
it's like she's doing something to it.
She's making it bigger. The only episode
I ever accidentally saw that show lies.
Let me see your DVR right now.
So I was the one,
she had her like ass x ray to like try
to prove that there was no implants.
Really. So that only leaves
like a couple of other options.
It's a good use of healthcare resources.
Well,
how do we know it's a real doctor
by the way? If it was covered, shit,
his insurance,
I mean most of the,
like when they walk into a place and
everybody goes, oh hi, nice to see you.
There's a fucking camera already there.
They're showing you an
over the shoulder shot.
It's a fucking camera behind you and
you're pretending you didn't know she was
coming.
We had a stop that he had a reality show
coming into one of the doctor's office
I worked in and I was like,
I think she was like a
gymnast or something and they
just came in with cameras.
But of course they were supposed
to pretend like, oh, hey,
you know what's wrong with you?
It's fucking ridiculous.
They don't have real
reality shows anymore.
What they have is like these low end
producer guys who look sort of dictate
what's going to happen in these scenes
and then these clumsy fucks act it out.
I watched a whole episode of Jersey shore
the other day in my green room before
a show where the situation wanted to
leave and nobody else wanted to leave.
And that was the whole show.
And I'm not exaggerating,
sneaky, no, no, no, no, no.
They were at a club or a club and
uh, you know one's guy like, hey,
you know the mall, he's an Asshole,
but it is for me because you know,
they get all the beaches and then snuck.
He was like, I'm not leaving. Fuck you.
I'm not leaving. And he's like, it's
time to go. Like you wanted to leave.
Nobody else wanted to leave.
And that was the whole thing was them
playing on this and you got to know like
99% of that's horse shit. That's doesn't,
they're not really having this argument.
They just decide that this is
what it's going to be tonight.
Tonight it's going to be the situation.
Tries to get girls,
but he's too aggressive so he wants to
leave and then they, you know, they have,
they did make it drama. They, they
turned it into like a script I live had,
there's a channel called real TV,
but every single show on it's fake fake
reality shows. Well you remember what,
how they're doing minding the store.
You know,
when they were doing the Pauly shore,
uh, comedy thing, comedy store thing,
or they had like a scenario that they
would do every day. I look at it,
that's how they do all,
they don't trust that it would be like
interesting enough to just follow your
wife. I think it was Rutgers that paid
snuck. He like 40 g to speak there.
I was like, if I was a
student, I did fucking quit.
Like I'm not paying my tuition to
pay sneaky to teach me life lessons.
You get a refund.
It would be fascinating.
Now if she couldn't leave of,
she had a certain amount of time and
she had to answer questions, come on.
That would be fun. That would be, she
can't just not worth 40 grand, but yes,
I wouldn't know. $40 I would
sit through that and watch that.
It'll be fascinating though, just to pick
her brain. I don't, you know, I'm, I'm, I,
I wouldn't, I don't hate her.
She, who wouldn't do that if they,
if you were, you were her, she was you. I
would fuck it. Do exactly the same thing.
That's the thing was shitty
people in general, like
you think like, all right,
if I were given the power to do this,
this, and this, what I act any different.
If I were like a riot cop and I was
coming from that background and like a,
B and c were set up as such, could
I be any different, you know,
well, you become with the riot cops
are real extreme example. Obviously
pick the most experienced the most. Mostly
you're, you're on the enemy. You know,
you, you just, it becomes you versus them.
There's no way of avoiding that and you'd
have to be from a different culture.
You know, I think there's a,
things have happened in some,
some countries where the,
the people and the police officers
don't have the same sort of antagonistic
relationship to the United States. People
do. But in the United States, if you are,
if you're a riot cop in this riot,
you're the enemy. You know, it's like,
you know that guy's got a club and he's
wearing a bulletproof vest and a fucking
helmet. It's, you would,
it'd be real hard for you to not act in
self preservation by staying with the
group.
We were discussing that
like level of escalation,
how the police were allowed to be like
one level of hostility above you and they
have like clear define levels of
hostility and if, if you're at one level,
they can be one level
above you at all times,
which I guess it's supposed to be
a deterrent from picking up a rock.
But the problem is at the same time they
have people that are in clothes that
are police officers doing things
like that to antagonize the crowd.
So they can move to the next
level. Yeah. The next escalation they're
called agent provocateurs. They just,
it was one of the occupy photos.
It's hilarious.
You see these fucking cops and the cops,
I'll have these Vibram work duty
in boots on and so did the guys.
They're handcuffing handcuffing your bio
protestors and they all have the same
fucking boots on.
It is the most ridiculous thing because,
and then people could say, well would
anybody could buy those boots? Yeah,
but everybody, all three of those
guys like the black hats on.
You're watching a puppet show.
I mean you're watching a puppet show now.
Now you're watching them act.
This is,
these guys are acting like they're
bad guys now. Like it's like a show.
Like cops are arresting cops,
they're arresting cops and then it
gives them the power to go in and arrest
everybody else. Cause now we obviously
have a violent protest so we escalate.
So instead of it being what it really is,
it becomes a show.
There's a video of one of them
like kicking a window in and a,
it's like a real tight video.
If you watch it from like the media side,
but there's actually someone recording
it with a phone really far away and when
you look at their angle, you can see not
only like all the media surrounding him,
not stopping him,
but there's police across the corner
or like across the street just standing
there like letting him bash the
window in and it was just right.
It's perfect. It feeds
into the police line. Like,
I mean they love the black
bloc shit like a NATO and Ga.
Like there were people
running around like,
like someone like lit a cop crown fire,
and they were just,
the cops didn't do anything about it.
It just gives them justification to just
do mass arrests and use crowd control
methods that are completely unjustified.
Yeah, and for people who think that
that's horseshit, you just need to watch.
There's a, there's a documentary, I
mean it's an Alex Jones documentary,
which ones settle in, but it's a nine
11, the road to tyranny. And what, what,
what's in it that's the most spectacular
is that he details and outlines the,
the introduction of these agent
provocateurs into this peaceful, um,
a settlement or this
peaceful a disagreement.
So these people are all protesting
everyone. There's no rocks thrown,
nothing's happening.
And then all of a sudden these dudes
come in and they're dressed in black and
they have military boots on and they
started breaking windows and turning cars
over and going crazy. And then they all
hold up in a fucking building, something.
I,
I don't even want to get into it and full
depth cause it's a long and drawn out
thing,
but he details it with news accounts.
He's showing you the actual footage
of what's going on. He, and it's,
it's preposterous.
Like you look at it and then what happens
after it will act after the police
came in and broke up the peaceful protest
and, and, and it turned into violence.
And then the arrest, all the, uh, the
fake cops or the fake fake protestors,
then they make a no protest zone.
So you can't even have,
it was the World Trade Organization.
You couldn't even have people that had
a badge on with a red stripe through the
WTO. They were stopping
them from going to work.
These people had book bags with
WTO on it and they're like,
this is a no protest zone. A fucking
no protests on. Like, you can't go.
And this is all, I mean, it's not, there's
the, the narrative aside, it's, you know,
this is all documented. It's all very
clear. It shows you the car, the car,
you see the cop tell her to take
the fucking pin off of her book bag.
And like what HR three 47. Yeah. Well,
it's also, you know, I mean,
when they get really nutty,
it's when they start talking about Timothy
Mcveigh in Oklahoma City and how many
antiterrorism provisions were
passed right after Oklahoma City.
All these different things that they
could do after that was passed in order to
surveil into,
do you so what used to be illegal
surveillance and that building, you know,
that's that whole thing is crazy.
That Timothy Mcveigh thing,
if you talk to people that
are demolitions experts,
they said there's no way a truck filled
with fertilizer can make an explosion
like that. It's not what it does. I said,
it doesn't have that kind of an impact.
Does it mean they can, you can kill
people with it, no doubt about it,
but it's not going to blow the whole
fucking building apart like that.
That's an insane bomb and probably not
even just one bomb and it blew everything
outward. Like if you look at
them, the point of impact,
the guy parks his truck right in the front
of the building and then blows it up,
right? That's, that's what
we're supposed to believe. Well,
the fucking buildings blown outward. Like
there's most of the buildings missing.
Like the whole front of the building's
gone and fertilizer in a fucking truck
can do that. He was supposed to have
as this fertilizer. Yeah, but, but no,
because the FBI,
they have the news footage of the Spi
taking bombs that didn't explode and
removing them from the building.
They had a bomb squad that
removed additional bombs
from the building because in
the moments after September
or after Oklahoma City,
there was a lot of confusion as to what
happened before they put the narrative
out there and before they say that
this is what happened, this is the guy.
And there was a lot of confusion
as to what really took place.
And while that confusion is being
taken by sis, news reports of FBI guys,
we're moving bombs from the building
and those were never like tied to him in
the trial or anything like that.
Now there is also very important now the
second guy who was in the car the whole
time, like just another, yeah. And
not only that, the, um, the, the, the,
the agents who were in that building all
evacuated the building before the bomb
went off.
Yeah. This is pre internet media, right?
So of course when you put
out the official narrative,
it fills in the gaps in people's
minds. Yeah. It's like a, you ask, uh,
an acquaintance, what'd you think
of the hot girl wearing the red hat?
We just pass by. Most people go, yeah, she
was hot. Even if that girl did not exist,
right? You fill in the
blanks and especially after
something traumatic happens,
you want somebody out there with
the voice of authority to say,
this is what happened. Now you know,
now it's not a fucking mystery.
We can move on with our lives. And you
pretty much accept whatever they say.
Yeah, no doubt. No doubt about it.
I mean, it's, it's, it's, it's,
we live in a shocking world and if
something like operation Northwoods is
possible,
that one point in time they had decided
they were going to sacrifice American
lives. And then you hear about
the Dick Cheney plan to do this.
The very same thing in Iran at the
end of the Bush administration. You,
you got to wonder what we're,
what we don't know about
what about General Wesley Clark's coming
out and I think it was 2007 where he
said that he was given that paper,
uh,
classified memos saying that they wanted
to invade seven countries in five years.
And this was all laid out.
Yeah.
This is like a week after nine
or something like here it is.
What did it say?
What the other countries where,
cause I'm sure can pull it up online.
Do you want to pull it up on mine suite
here? Wesley Clark Sad. Brian one.
Find that because it's,
if you want us,
the last piece of hope and in between
that and just agent provocateurs,
there's been a lot of uh,
uh,
agents like going in and using like
entrapment techniques to like get people
arrested. Well, of course, not only that,
they've actually supplied them with,
they could have never had in the first
place something like 18 year old kid
who's just like, you know,
he can be taught, I mean,
so like vulnerable and can be
talking about all FBI facilitation.
They could not do what they are saying
that they can do without the FBI
completely controlling and manufacturing
the way just providing him with it.
It's like talking them
into doing well by the way,
introducing that idea into
their head. I mean, right.
When you have a person and that person
benefits from getting you to do something
that is illegal and they
benefit by getting a collar,
they'd benefit and you didn't,
you didn't have this plan in effect
until you came into contact with them.
How could that possibly be legal?
Because you're just counting
the possibility that that
could be influencing,
first of all,
what kind of a deceptive person are they
that they can pretend they're so good,
they can trick you and B,
they could pretend that they're on your
side when meanwhile they're the enemy.
I mean, if you're, if you're
a terrorist and the FBI is in,
in the myths and pretending
to be one of you,
he's such a good manipulator that
he can pretend to be you. I mean,
this guy's an excellent bullshitter.
And then on top of that,
he comes up with a plan.
Listen man,
we're going to stick it to the man and
you're like, Hey, what are we going to do?
I want to get you some c four who had
to blow this motherfucker. You're like,
are you sure about that? And you're
like, oh yeah, I got it covered.
Let me just do everything.
That guy that got arrested in Dallas,
that kid was a fucking moron.
I mean,
he was a dumb kid and they talked to
him in to making this attack. They,
they gave him a fake bomb and
they let him try to detonate it.
They tell them everything to do.
They did and they failed this
kid up with hypnosis. I mean,
I'm not discounting the fact that he,
you know,
anybody that is willing to
just detonate this fake bomb,
it should be removed anyway.
I mean they did an awesome service cause
they got a fucking moron off the street.
And if it wasn't the FBI that
talk this kid in a doing that,
it could have been actual terrorist
is a moron. That guy's that guys,
I'm glad I didn't run into
him at the supermarket.
Some extent you need people like that
who are infiltrating groups just to get
rid of the supermarket.
Uh,
I think we've seen evidence of it going
away too far where they are the problem.
Like well how about the one in Florida
where they're hiring undercover cops to
pretend to be high school students to
get weed getting stronger and, and laws.
And this is something that
we could actually fix.
Well how about the one where there's a
25 year old woman who convinces a 17 year
old honor roll student and get her weed?
Some horn tries to give it to her as a
gift and she insisted he take money for
it and then he's arrested because
she's so horny. Little, no nothing kid.
And he gets fucking locked
away. It's insane. It's insane.
But yet this is all done with
tax dollars. You know, we're,
we're paying for them to entrap
17 year olds with boners the bed.
The best story of entrapment
that was hardcore failure was this guy.
And then they get paid like hundreds of
thousands of dollars do this over the
course of six months to a year.
I mean really longterm shit.
And so this guy was in a mosque trying
to rally up like some terrorist activity
and they actually reported hinder the
FBI there like some crazy motherfucker
isn't here trying to like talk to him.
We got this one
so silly. It's so awkward. Surveillance.
Well the Da,
if the fact that they can go,
they have the time to go
after pot when there's math,
it's like did you clean up all the math?
You didn't clean up the mess
because the pots recently,
some kid wrote like fuck the DEA on his
Facebook page and now he's being charged
with a felony or something saying, well I
apparently threatened me. You just said,
you know, said something
fucked up. There's three words.
It's not the most eloquent, eloquent way
to argue against the agency's policies.
But if that's what puts you in prison,
like learning the word well,
agencies are a problem.
It's a problem.
When you boil things down to three
letters, when you have power,
because of those three letters you say
open up, it's the FBI. Like Holy Shit,
the FBI's here. It's not like
no knock knock. Who is it? Well,
my name is Mike and on the machine guns
is Peter and Tom and behind them is a
delivery with a battering Ram
and Bob's his backup and a,
well we're here because we heard that you
uh, you have some plants or something.
I mean that doesn't sound right, but
open up. It's the DEA like Holy Shit,
the DEA is here.
Like whenever you have people like that
in a group and you give them like a
little name like that, it just puts some
mythical fucking no. Yeah. It's like,
it's like it's a giant power group.
Pick them off stealing goods.
What's tragic about that is like you said,
the math is still out there.
Like these agencies have an actual role.
And instead they focused
on the wrong shit.
Like it'd be great to get meth out of
people's hands because it destroys lives.
The great if you've got an Oxycontin,
so it'd be great if the FBI focused on
the tremendous amount of financial fraud
happening right now.
Like half the emails and my fucking
spam folder or people directly trying to
defraud me out of money in some
way. That's just amazing. Nigerians,
I know a lot of us, a lot of that
spans so many, so many people.
I don't fall for that shit,
but my point is a lot of
people out there in America do,
especially older people who don't
use the internet as much. Yeah.
That should be looked into.
And the people who directly benefited
from the financial crisis that should be
looked into.
It's not,
instead they're focused on fucking
occupiers and journalists. Well,
the problem is it's compartmentalize too.
It's like how many people do they have
that are on the police force and whatever
Florida town that was there supposed
to be gathering up, we'd, you know,
I mean how many, how many people did they
have that are supposed to get arrest?
Like, it's not like those people
can instead be allocated, you know,
in some sort of a positive way.
Like you'd have to like change their job
because if their job is to go out and
bust people for drugs,
well that's their job and they're going
to do it as long as that job exists.
And if that job doesn't exist,
well then they're out of work and
they got to find something new to do.
So they're going to resist that job being
being taken away as well. So it's, it's,
it gets to be a weird
thing of entanglement where
we have private prisons,
we have, you know, cops
and, and, and police officers,
unions that are lobbying to
keep certain things illegal.
We have a big entanglement.
Yeah, no, yeah. Also,
banks are laundry and trillions of
dollars with the drug money. Yeah.
Oh yeah.
What was that a Wacovia?
It's like 400 400 something million
dollars, which is so stupid.
Make the shit legal, make everything
legal, stop being silly. You know? Let,
let people make their own fucking choices.
And if you want to do math,
you're going to get in any way you're
going to get math and you know,
we should fucking heavily punished any
company that wants to sell it to the
point where it's not even financially
viable. Take that money. If you're going,
you really sell math, you're fucking
touch a piece of shit. I mean,
it's not like the data's not in,
it's not like there's meth advocates out
there going, dude, my life was terrible.
So I started smoking the nap and it's
like, I just saw it different. I was like,
I didn't need to be kinder to people.
That doesn't happen.
There's no math advocate.
So if you're selling meth,
you're a piece of shit as far as society
is concerned and we should tax you
heavily. Yeah. You maybe make a living
off of it and maybe feed some Cretins,
you know?
But people should be responsible for
their actions when they're on drugs.
That's when they commit crimes.
It's not the fact that you're on drugs.
If you want to do math and lock yourself
in the basement and just fucking hulk
out and smashing into walls and shit.
I don't know what I'm saying.
But if you don't do anything to people,
who the fuck is anybody to
tell you you can't do that?
And how do we have a free society if
you can be told what plants you can put
into your own body,
it's not only that they can shoot you
because there's a 17 year old kids are
getting like their chances for getting
into college or like ruined forever cause
I got caught with a joint.
You know they don't think of that
school they need the internet.
School's going to be awesome to get laid,
but that's where the harmony comes in.
Just need to get on you harm
and just put together a day date,
a dope profile and you know really
like come up with some good quotes.
Sort about craigslist is the verdict.
Well if you want to hook her,
that's what she needs to go or a couch
or out. Then the media narrative,
like just immediately putting it out into
the mainstream to try to solidify some
sort of narrative or right after nine
11 my mom was like, uh, Uber Patriotic,
you know the flag phone case,
fucking first bag out on the
block and shit and stuff.
My brother and I just discovered this
giant box of magazines and newspapers
right after nine 11 and you should see
it. I mean Newsweek, Time magazine,
like two days after nine 11 already
explaining exactly. You know,
everything laid out,
all the hijackers bin Ladin the how
the buildings fell down and all the
countries that going to invade in
the next 10 years. And you're like,
if you had this much information and they
had to have been fed it just directly
by the government,
I'm like,
then how come they couldn't prevent
it if they'd already knew all the shit
within 24 hours to print this publication?
Right.
You have the mind that the nine 11 events
were orchestrated or it's incompetent
I think in part orchestrated for sure.
That's undeniable.
I mean just the put options
alone shows that, well that's,
that could just say for knowledge the
put options where all of the, I mean,
you bet for stocks to
fail on any given day.
A lot of people bet for certain stocks
and fail. But on this particular day,
all the airlines that
were involved in nine 11,
we're bet 25 times more
that they would fail.
So all these rich white people
pretty much profited immensely.
So someone's failed stocks.
Someone had to be tipped off and then,
and then they didn't pursue
it because they said, well,
because it wasn't done by Al Qaeda,
then we're not interested in
pursuing the money ring in your like.
But that's much more interesting that it
was done by old white men that bet for
these stocks to fail.
That's much more fascinating to me.
Do we know if there's a list somewhere
of people who benefited? I don't know.
But also people were warned
not to fly Willie Brown. Uh,
some other people will have admitted
that they were told not to fly. So,
I mean there,
there definitely was for knowledge,
but if you're going into nine 11,
I mean the hijack,
some of the hijackers lived
with the old mayor. Yeah. Um,
two of the hijackers lived at Pensacola
naval base with under the roof of an FBI
informant. I mean that's, that's
documented. That's mainstream
news.
So do you think that they set the whole
thing up and do you think they were real
hijackers and how'd they get
people to suicide? Bombed?
They were patsy. They don't think that
they knew that they were going to die.
I don't know. I mean, I
don't want to speculate.
All I know is what I'm
being told is a lie.
How much have you looked into
the, uh, the flying aspect? Alas,
the flying aspect is fascinating when you
talk to people that actually fly those
jets and talk about how difficult
it is to maneuver them correctly,
especially the one where
it hits the Pentagon.
That's fucking fascinating.
And there's no pieces of
planes and we'll not only that,
that area where it hits is the same area
where Donald Rumsfeld was on television
just a day before talking about
this trillion plus dollars.
It's missing some, some dangerous
amount of money that's missing.
And then the accounting office in the
Pentagon shut down is what gets hit by
this plane. I mean, that's
where the plane lands.
It's the very offices that we're storing
all the data that we're looking for,
where the mothers in construction
in that side of the building,
I think at,
at the very least,
they knew exactly what was coming and
they helped make it happen at the very
fucking lease, which should piss
people off just as fucking match.
Because think about it, if they knew
that this terrorist attack was coming,
so they tell people in the first World
Trade Center, whatever the, the, you know,
after the first ones hit,
they knew that it was the terrorist
attack that they had been warned about.
And then they told people to go to
fucking back to work in the Second World
Trade Center
hang.
It piqued my interest when I was here.
A lot of thing like theories about
that was the building seven. Yeah.
That was like the videos
of that or just it?
It looks exactly like if you put it
right next to a video of of an an
intentionally imploded building.
Like it just looks exactly the same.
Yeah. The, the tower seven,
this mind fuck of a half because the real
thing about tower seven as if it was a
controlled demolition.
What did they build it that way?
Did they build it so they could
just implode it and if they didn't,
how long did it take to rig that?
Cause you talked to people that
like demolish buildings. That's you.
It takes a long time. And if it
didn't, if it wasn't a demolition,
why would you not sue like crazy.
If that was my building and
it just fell apart like that
and I'd be like, bitch, how'd you build
this? Is Larry Silverstein confident?
He has like 20 mil dude off
off the whole complex roofers.
Yeah. Guys. The truth.
I find it so scary that that's the
word that's been pushed out there.
Now it's being pushed on totally different
topics that have nothing to do with
nine 11 like it's kind of where William,
that a truth or is now a piece of
shit like somebody who's interested in
pursuing what the truth was about nine
11 that's like truth or the one patriotic
cruisers and it's like
a funny being a truth.
It's almost like straight out of 1984
these fucking unpatriotic true thirst.
They want the truth. Well, how
about being a liberal? Yeah, I,
I've been called libertarian
like it's an insult before,
which I'm not even a libertarian.
I have some of their views,
but it's like you really,
you hate people who want to have
more personal freedoms and liberties.
That's a bad thing. Why is
that a bad thing? It's, it's
weird. It's crazy. We're,
we're nuts. Oh, you one of those love
fucking up his world. What are you a
friend, your friend going to be my friend.
Found out my friend. Fuck face. I
don't want friends from American. Well.
Also, another interesting thing about
the nine 11 thing is that if we,
the s there was a CIA sting operation
to get the Bin Ladin Confession tape,
quote Unquote Confession tape
that's admitted by the Guardian,
like that was set up by the CIA to
get him to supposedly confessed.
So if we had him, why didn't we just
arrest him then? That was in 2001 well,
what do you think about this
guy who wrote the book and the,
the Navy seal wrote the
book on the assassination of
Bin Ladin and he's given a
totally different version of the
events than the official story.
How does that guy, you're allowed to make
that book. How can we have an ice dam?
I don't, I don't know if I
believe cause I mean I'm not sure.
I think they realize that the public
knows that, um, you know, they're,
the official story is
never exactly correct,
but you're allowed to say this.
What was the last time a guy was
involved in like a secret operation?
Wrote a book about it. It doesn't make
any sense. Yeah. It's almost like you're,
they give him the green. I don't
under they give him the green light.
Did they tell him, listen man,
you want to do help? You crunchy.
I like to write a book about the events.
Just mix it up a little.
It looks like we're like not telling
the full truth and we're like,
bring it back.
Don't say anything.
When in season five we bring back
the sound wasn't really Osama,
it was this other dude that looks like
Osama because he's in love with Osama,
you know he wants to
be Osama but he's not.
So they shot him in the heads of it even
know so they thought they got Osama.
They really did think that got him.
We've been holding back on the DNA.
We've had the DNA. We've kept it secret
because they didn't want to alarm people
still out there. He was on the
island. I love that you NGA,
when [inaudible] speaks every year,
everyone like walks out,
but he's actually said some
really same shit. He's just like,
how come you guys just dump and
laudens body in the ocean? Like,
how come you didn't just arrest
him and put him on trial? They can,
everyone's like walking out like,
because he like the real life version
of the dictator, like a document.
But it gives the UN speech
there and people are like, no.
Most people that are in the
intelligence community said that,
that he was already dead. They said been
a lot of that had been dead for years.
Our butoh came out and Pakistani prime
minister, he for, she was assassinated,
can't you said to see attended
his funeral to ease those Grice.
She said she attended his funeral. Hmm.
This bitch. Cause we get problematic.
Pesky truth. Predator, pesky
traffic or ground. Never say it.
Common like Predator and like a second,
a third vote.
I don't even think they vote on it.
This thing about all this is that no
one demands evidence or no one demands
facts from the government. So that's just
appeal to authority. You're just like,
well, let's just trust our
government must be true.
It's not no one because there's
people like you right now,
there's a whole wave of kids
that are growing up that are um,
people growing up with real transparency
as far as what's going on. You know,
and even if you want to insulate yourself
Salou give yourselves a pat on the
back of your, yeah,
yeah. It's fucking nasty.
Horrible started.
Sorry Dave Asprey.
I didn't have time to make the
bulletproof coffee that I use.
I can't believe it's not butter. It's
not the same point. Nice coffee. No,
you just pour it in there.
We had this guy on yesterday who makes a,
he's a fucking super cool dude and
just incredibly fascinating guy.
And one of the things he was saying was
that we have in an amazing amount of
toxins that we just accept because
there's so much corn in our diets and like
some,
some insane number of percentage of corn
has like certain low level toxic fungus
on it.
Totally edible.
I pissed off how you drink a lot of
water that's actually healthy, but that,
that you know,
you should really have only grass fed
beef and only grass fed beef butter.
And that coffee off oftentimes
comes with a fungus on it as well.
And there's toxic funguses and a
lot of people's coffee and that.
They're literally,
that's why they get,
they feel like shit after they drink
coffee. Literally you're getting poisoned.
It's not this club, this is all organic.
We'd go, we'd go to a nice place.
It's down the street. It's very
nice people. Um, but that, um,
he makes his bulletproof coffee so
he takes his butter and MCT oil.
Mct Oil is,
you take coconut oil and he's sticking
in a centrifuge and take the best part of
it, the most nutritious part. And then he
puts it, separates it and makes an oil,
puts that in the coffee butter.
That's from a only grass fed cows.
Cause apparently the,
the um,
the fats in that are much
more healthy for your body.
And he mixes it all together in a blender
with his coffee and he just sits back
and shot himself in the head. Fucking
guy was a trip, man, that guy,
there's very few people that really
freaked me out. This guy freaked me out.
What was the whole point of drinking
that that's sensational for your body?
All the, uh, the, the fatty
acids, all the, the, uh, the oils,
the healthy oils from the MCT oil
and from the grass fed butter.
So sensational for brain function.
You're, you just feel like you're on fire.
It's like really great stuff and get
it doesn't like burn you out as easy
because I don't understand.
He explained how it's uh,
how they interact with each other and
how, how positive it is for your, uh,
for your brain.
But he had a,
all these crazy things that he did and
one of them was go to this place that,
that thing with the sound where you
manipulate sound with your mind.
You're set up with electrodes and you
literally manipulate sounds with thought
and in, in, in,
in which your mind and brainwaves and
you're in an isolated place where it's
total blackness and you're doing this
and apparently it's been shown to rewire
your brain and the more control
over you have over the sound.
It's like power lifting for your brain
and you come out of it with a permanent
boost in your Iq. He boosted his
Iq 20 points from this seven day,
every day,
all day experience of this Guy Magneto.
Sounds like maybe that's what I'm talking
about. Fuck out. And you walk in there.
Well listen, the guy was smart as fuck.
He wasn't fake smart as fuck. So I,
I had to like listen
to everything he said.
And I know that research and science
backs almost every single different aspect
of that. The health part of his
bulletproof diet that he's talking about.
I read all the stuff. I mean it's, it's
all, it seems like it seems rock solid.
So this guy is like this super genius
character who is claiming that 20% or
rather a 20 points of his Iq was boosted
by doing this fucking crazy sound
experiment and the dark for seven days.
He scared the shit out of me.
Where did he claim where, where do you
do this? BC. That's where he lives.
He lives up in BC.
And he did he sent this up or is it like
a research project someone was doing or
oh no, well it's, it's, you know,
I don't, I don't remember entirely,
but it's based on the research of
some neuroscientists to figure it out.
Something about manipulating brainwaves
with electricity and stimulation.
So he puts these little electrodes on
his head and he sends like a low volt to
change his, uh, his state, you know, from
Alpha to Beta or whatever the fuck it is.
You know, he's got like, you know,
like different settings on
it and I put it on pinched.
I said that it felt like a,
like a a B was just touching you at the
tip of his horn is a little stinger,
just not stinging you but
just say [inaudible] could
just fuck you up right now
dude,
but not quite.
And so this guy is obsessed with,
with like manipulating his
mind and like hacking his body.
So he takes in all of these incredible
amounts of essential nutrients and he's
eating like the healthiest grass fed
meat and he's fucking electrifying his
brain and he's going to his place in
manipulating things with sound and getting
smarter, like notably visibly smarter.
And I know he's smart as fuck.
He can't fake it for two hours. There's
a certain amount of talking to someone.
We can tell if someone's we like,
I've had people on the podcast before
that I knew were full of Shit within like
the first 20 minutes talking to them.
But the first 15 minutes I might've
thought they were pretty cool.
And then somewhere along the line to go,
there's this guy's a little wacky,
there's something, something,
something wrong here. There's some,
this guy was not like that.
This guy was just firing off all
this fucking information about how to
streamline your,
your,
your mind and how to make things work
better and what nutrients are essential
and what they do and how it literally,
it enhances the way your nerve endings,
your nerve endings
interact. He eats Yak. Yak was
delicious. It was delicious,
but they only eat a certain type of a
plant and you can't even grow it at low
altitudes so they don't like live down
here. It's like tough to get a Yak,
Yak in your backyard because you grow
Yak food. It just fucking just dies.
Idiot to who? Collect
exotic pets. I was just,
we were just talking about it outside
all the idiot too. I would like python,
fucking chimpanzees and Kangaroos and
there's like beauty pageants for exotic
animals. Didn't know what a chimpanzee
was until that one eight that lady's face.
People thought the chimpanzees were
like Bj and the bear, you know,
like to see your buddy. He goes
trucking with you. You know,
like they were always sidekicks
and movies and shit. Like,
people didn't see the videos of
chimps eating monkeys alive. You know,
they've never seen a champ attack a
person they didn't know about these chimps
in Africa right now that are going to,
that forget one particular part or Africa
where they're actually going actively
out of their way to kill humans
and they've killed, uh, you know,
I've got to pull that up because
that sounds like terrorism.
I think we should go and start a war.
That's exactly what we're doing to them.
So that's a shock to
they're doing it back.
Well, the row there, um, there
were reacting. It's in a Congo,
the eat them like crazy in the Congo.
It's called Bushmeat.
The lions in Africa that
were intentionally hunting
humans and like keeping
their bones in a cave or oh yeah.
That was the ghost and the darkness.
That's pretty big. Back when val
Kilmer was sexy and slim for Batman.
Yeah, back man. I just fucking
tapped out. And it's like, yeah,
imagine that this thing,
Congo chimps reporting and killing people.
Imagine that thing. And here's the thing
is they go right for your fingers first.
That's what they like to rip apart first.
Cause they know you can't fight
back when you don't have fingers.
So they immediately go after your fingers,
like grabbed your hand and eat your
fucking fingers and you can't stop them.
You can't stop them. They're way
stronger than you. They have your hand,
they're just going to chew
your fucking fingers off.
And then they go after your Dick.
They go off to your Dick,
they rip your Dick off, they
kill your sexually, and then
they go after your face.
They pull your eyes
out like they're smart.
They know they're not even killing you.
They kill you easy.
They could pick up a rock and just
start smashing you and you'd be dead.
But they're punishing you.
They are punishing, punishing
you by taking away your,
your humanness, taking one of your ability
to see things, your sex organs. I mean,
it's crazy. They take your feet apart.
They attack people's feet. Yeah.
And they're smart. You know,
they can spell, you know,
they shouldn't be in cages.
I mean there's,
there's,
there's no way there should be a healthy
separation between people and these
fucking things in the real world
because they do that to each other.
They go after other chimps and
they fucked him up. I mean,
it's amazing that they're just
now starting to gang up on people.
But 10 people have been killed.
17 people have been severely
injured and uh, they,
they killed one little kid.
They don't give a fuck. Why
would they not kill a kid?
They don't like people that don't
like people. They don't like to say,
well it's only been like six.
I just want to let them,
they think this is an easy kill.
Yeah. It's just scary shit man.
I was listening to one of your,
where you're talking to
a guy who came back from China,
is it,
they love to eat and monkeys
and certain parts of China.
So it's really not that much different
from what we do in terms of other
cultures of humans.
Like I think it's appalling that somebody
would hunt down a monkey and fucking
eat it.
Just not even cause you need the meat.
But just for pleasure because
it's considered like a
high status thing to have
monkey on the table,
you know? That is weird.
More fucked up to do that or more fucked
up to have drones that shoot rockets
into buildings and you know you're going
to get like 98% I think drones are,
drones are a little more fucked up.
Yeah.
What is the percentage is 2%
versus 98% fuck up, right?
Many percent accidental murder.
That's what we're getting for all
those buildings to fight terror.
That's the only way. That's the only
way I'm going to bust some myths.
That right there isn't it?
So you have these two combating
narratives with like the liberal and
conservative establishment
where you're like,
we either have to have full fledged
warfare or we have drone wars,
but no one's questioning do we need,
maybe we don't need any.
I'm showing you to be fucking fighting
this proverbial enemy that doesn't really,
it's not a very central way cooler
we can do with that technology. Yeah.
Well we can,
the amount of money we spent in Iraq
and Afghanistan would have funded like a
little over 400 missions.
Uh,
the same size and significance
is the curiosity mission to Mars.
I did the math on that and uh,
I get the math.
Well that was the Neil degrasse Tyson
isn't that fucking psycho though.
Like the money that we spent
in Iraq and Afghanistan,
which the average American citizen
is received zero benefit from,
we could have launched 400 missions
around the solar system and it killed a
million people aside from the Shit
we learned from doing all that.
It's the jobs that we would,
we would create right here in the u s
cause you don't outsource NASA jobs to
China. They stay here in the
u s it's crazy. Yeah. It's,
it's interesting that this,
this industry is thought of as like by
the people that are in charge I guess as
the only way of having this
amount of business going on.
It's like that's the only way.
Instead of thinking of taking the same
sort of initiative at the same amount of
focus and resources and putting it
on just building up inner cities,
just fixing Detroit. You know, if
you've seen the signs and Detroit,
now they're saying enter
Detroit at your own risk.
It's like they're posting siren sang
in terrible places saying people should
enter it. Their own risk.
It's like saying like,
I guess cops aren't going to go in there.
Like the murder rate in
Detroit is through the roof.
It's the scariest place in the country.
Right.
In the city council there was telling
people not to come like, yeah, I,
which is like weird cause you,
you know crazy.
It's good for their economy to have people
come in and it's for them to say that
it's gotta be really serious.
Yeah.
The fact that we're over in Afghanistan
and we're not in Detroit. I was crazy,
awesome campaigns looking at the
cops don't want to go into Detroit.
You should look,
there's no way a country can
be strong when the base of it,
the bottom of it is fucked up and
rotten and the bottom of this country,
the foundation of this country
is youth and poor neighborhoods.
Though the higher we can make the
quality of life for our poor people,
the better the whole thing works.
The more accessible like happiness
and wealth is to poor people,
the more it's possible to, to, to gain
and achieve and to get out of there. The,
the,
the stronger.
The whole thing gets like the idea that
we have this finite amount of jobs. No,
we just have a finite amount of jobs
with this system, with this system,
but there's obviously a
lot of work to be done.
There's a shit load of things that need
to get done and not everybody's going to
get to be Tom Cruise,
but a lot of people do a lot of really
good fucking things that it is possible
that we could use the same resources,
the same billions of dollars that we're
allocating to going over places that we
don't really understand for
whatever fucking reason. You
know, it's not the truth.
We could do that over here.
It doesn't seem to be impossible.
It just doesn't seem to be probable
under this situation. And this,
the group that's in charge right now
has such a stranglehold that they don't
want to ever make. You think that it's
possible to do things any differently.
Like we're always going
to be at war with Iran.
We're never going to totally trust Russia.
China is always dangerous.
We don't know what they're really saying.
I think China really is dangerous
though, just my opinion. But yeah,
I think based on what I've seen, they have
no respect for human rights. No. And uh,
they're growing at such a rate that they
have to keep their middleclass happy
and that's not going to happen forever.
I mean,
already it's started seeing
signs of a slow down,
like a credit crunch and a slow down.
You're going to get desperate. Exactly.
I mean,
there's only so many resources in the
world and so much wealth and they need
more of it to keep their middle
class from attacking them basically.
Have they had a policy of,
of attacking other countries in the past.
Have they worked on that?
A billion people and they want more and
more and they try to do things to stop
people from not saying
day like just the Chinese.
I'm saying you get any country with a
billion people that has just recently come
online and the capitalism game we're
having more shit is what you want to do.
They're going to start to acquire other
areas. Doesn't India have a billion too?
They do.
They just make Bollywood.
They just make movies
and they don't eat cows.
They don't, they're not
threatening anybody other than
the Pakistan though. Right.
It's also hilarious
about hearing how Iran,
when they get their
nuclear weapon or whatever,
that people are fearmongering
us about. Um, they're like,
they're going to start a nuclear
arms race in the Middle East,
but they don't talk about Israel.
Pakistan, fucking, I mean,
so many countries that have
nuclear stockpile. Funny.
Like Pakistan is sort of,
it was sort of a u s backed country.
There's a lot of us money going
in there over the last 60 years.
And India was sort of had the same
thing going on with Russia and you know,
Usr Ussr collapsed and yet India is a new
emerging country and Pakistan is doing
so shitty.
It's hilarious that we pay attention
to them like they're really dangerous.
Well we don't fuck with North Korea.
North Korea is scary there.
They are really brainwashed.
It's a nutty fucking country full
of people that will drop bombs.
It's depressing to the human costs.
They're like,
those people are 100%
brainwashed. Yeah. They brought,
they brought in an eye doctor, uh,
to fix some of the people's eyes
cause they had cataracts do whatever they
do for cataracts and chopped that part
out and replace it.
And they did this,
they actually brought in a film crew
and this was like the cover story.
They had to bring them into the countries
that are just filming the medical
procedures and it's scary.
They,
they would get their vision back instead
of back to the d instead of thanking
the doctor like you
dear leader for bringing
us our vision back. And it's like,
no, he didn't bring your vision back.
He's the reason why you have fucking
cataracts in the first place because you
working in a factory your whole life,
like dark lighting and chemicals
being sprayed in your face.
Did you see all the people that were
crying in the street when he died and that
people who weren't crying,
where actually there were locked in jail
for six months and punished and they
lost jobs and like they have
concentration camps. I mean,
you'd go there to work and die. Yeah, but
they don't have resources, so fuck them.
You know,
if they had oil,
we would have an awesome movie
about going to war with North Korea.
It's already know it would
be the big deal. Yeah.
But there's nothing there for us.
It's not worth it. It's not in there.
I saw some stats on
Twitter. It was like, uh,
can somebody please tell congress
that there's no oil on the Internet
tweeted that? That's hilarious. So the,
you know,
the only hope that I have for any of
this stuff actually turning around is I
think the people that have
been in power for a long time.
We got to keep eternal life from them.
We've got to make sure that they don't
actually get some sort of technology
where they could live forever
because then I'll never,
it's like there's so much
power in that position.
There's so much power in the position
of being in charge of the military
industrial complex being in charge of,
you know, where the money gets allocated,
being in charge of the influence
of presidents that, that,
that to get to that position.
I mean that is a,
an immense point of power and it's really
hard to wrench power when someone has
that and it's even harder to get them
to give it up because it's not moral.
And that seems to be the only way you're
ever really going to change things is
they have to leave. They have to
die off. And people like yourself,
young people that want to
get involved in politics,
have to move into these previously
corrupt roles and announced new standards.
They have to move in and announce a new
way of looking at things that people
thought we were getting with Obama.
That's what we were happy about.
We thought we were getting out of this
same fucking scary shit that we had with
this,
this corporate monster,
Dick Cheney pulling the strings
of this dumb dumb from Texas.
And we were terrified and we were like,
this guy does not represent us,
but that guy does look at him.
He's half black. It's a single mom.
He said came from single mom, used
to smoke weed, get 'em in all my God,
it's going to be the shit.
Meanwhile recruited Taz already
taken over and I think that uh,
it's just a matter of understanding
that and undermining the whole system.
We can't just wait for people to take
over these positions and then change it
from the top down.
That could never have got to fight.
You gotta fight both parties.
You can't just go after one or the other.
Put it in the system is
broken. Yeah. There's no system
that says no dude parties.
I mean, shit, it's all completely
shows like this are helping.
Like it's not just the
system we need to fix.
It's also people need to become aware.
There are a lot of people don't even
know this shit is happening right now.
They think that they still have a
government that kind of represents them.
By the way,
this is good for the government
too because unchecked
power is bad for you too.
You don't want to be in that position.
You should be checked. You should.
There should be regulations. It should
be there should be sale, but should be
safeguards in place to
protect you from human nature.
It should be very clean and very clear
and since we're moving into this age of
more access to information
than ever before,
it should be easier to check you than
ever before. You should be more noble.
You should be more just, it should be
more fair. It shouldn't be the opposite.
Shouldn't be more surveillance,
more storing of your fucking
phone calls without warrants more.
Whatever the crazy shit they're doing now.
It shouldn't be that.
That's a sign of a sickness.
That's a sign of you trying to hang on
to your addiction while you're trying to
do is isolate everybody
and get them away from you.
You're trying to force yourself into
a position where you can control the
situation because you don't want to
accept the fact that you're living in
uninvolved life and the people that are
in charge of whatever the fuck it is,
call it whatever you want,
whatever it is that's moving us into war,
whatever it is that's sucking oil out of
the ground and the way you get it is by
Jack and countries and holding onto the
resources, whatever the fuck that is,
they have to come to some sort of a
realization that this is an insane way to
live.
Yeah, it's the, it's the
resistance to change.
It's the resistance inevitability
that they do not want to accepts,
that they're trying very hard to
maintain us into this, uh, ideological
controlling. Great. They fear this
connection so badly. They fear this,
that it's coming down and that's why
they're trying to lock everything up.
And that's why they're trying to set
up these safe guards in place where
basically everything is legal.
They can just arrest you that you don't
have to have a lawyer. No, there's,
we have, you know, article
six, paragraph five.
We can go from fuck you
with hammers if we want to
talking about that. The thing that amber
was talking about at lunch with the, uh,
the new, uh, the new NDA
bill. Oh, that's scary.
I was talking to you right
before we started about
this, the 2013 Nda with them.
Well, there's a law right now that
basically says like the, the, the,
the government can't turn propaganda
against American citizens,
so they're not allowed to
like have all that, you know,
war propaganda posters
and stuff like that.
For some reason people in Congress have
decided that they want to undo that and
it's going to be kind of another
writer in the same way that indefinite
detention was on the 2012
Nda and what we were like,
we were just kind of
theorizing it launched.
One of the ways that they could use that
is by using government funding to hire
people to basically sit on Twitter.
All right.
That's what they already do. Well,
I mean, they already do it. I mean,
of course like when they were already
indefinitely detaining people before
they'll have the green light, the
league, right light and the resources.
So as time goes on and shit
gets more and more crazy,
they can just do anything they
want and it will all be legal.
So they've essentially made being a
dictator league that we can destroy social
media in the same way they
destroyed mainstream media.
Instead of having like war
there's on the wall,
what they'd have is like banks of
people sitting on Twitter all day,
like in for instance,
like going after Abby for like something
she says on her show and pretending not,
it's, they're not going to be labeled
as like a government Twitter account.
They're going to be like
pretending. They're never going to
have the amount of enthusiasm zoom
that the people fighting them are
because they're just going to be shitty
government employees that don't have that
in mind as what they want to be doing
with their lives. Whereas people that
are fighting it, they're led by a vision.
They're led by, they have a hope and
a dream for something being better.
And they have, they have passion.
These people, that's just their job.
It's just another obstacle in the people
that do things like that and just for a
job,
they suck at it.
Like there are people on my message board
that are probably government agents.
They're fucking terrible at it.
I know there was trying to buy weed
from people laziest Deh and ever,
you know, it's like it's, it's pretty
obvious man. There's, there's, you know,
in order to get people
to be as charismatic,
to be as educated on the subject,
to be as,
as aware of what young
people are tuned into.
You'd have to like become one of
them. You know, you'd have to,
if you were working for the government
and you were working and you were,
you were supposed to be like an agent
provocateur and you were working on the
Internet with more and more
access to the Internet,
you're going to start looking at shinny
and where the fuck am I working for?
You know, and if you're a 29
year old guy or 30 year old guy,
it's very possible that you would start
doing some things for the opposition.
It's very possible that a guy like
Bradley manning did exactly that,
that he's working for the government.
And you realize at one point
in time like holy shit,
like look at someone needs to see
this stuff. Like this is crazy stuff.
This is nuts. We're shooting these
reporters and they're joking about it.
They're making it seem
like it's no big deal.
And they're shooting a van full
of kids, you know, and to say,
well it shouldn't brought kids.
Like you're hearing shit like
that and you know what the fuck.
So this kid re releases it and now he's
an enemy of the state and they give him
the same brains, scrambled treatment
that they're giving people.
Donald, my dad, he's done. I mean, you
keep somebody in solitary for that long.
That is torture.
It's torture and Ruthie bruise your brand.
You need stimulation
with other human beings.
You need to see other people's faces.
You need that too.
Right. So she can never
testify. He could never,
he never like plead his case.
Like literally they wrote
and definitely not attention.
It has only been legal what?
Less than 365 days via the NDA.
But Bradley Manning's when in pretrial,
pretrial detention for over 900.
Now, how crazy is that? Nobody's,
nobody's scrambling to try to get that
kid out and nobody's talking about it is
part of their campaign strategy.
No politicians and the people are,
most, a lot of people care about this,
but to be honest,
there are a lot of people who don't.
And recently there was this
huge controversy about Reddit
Gawker, which, you know,
Walker,
it's a big gossip blog out of the identity
of one of the moderators on Reddit
who was behind some of their,
uh,
more a disgusting sections,
like one section posted photos of dead
girls who are under the age of 17.
That was like the specific purpose
of this community was to do that.
And there are a lot of people online
who are outraged that his identity was
revealed in this article. And
it was a grandfather, was he?
I don't know that much about, I know
he was in Texas, but, uh, they were,
they were so outraged.
They were so outraged about this,
that they blocked Gawker from posting
links on many parts of Reddit to like
starve them of traffic, which
gawkers popular regardless. But, uh,
I was seeing how fucking sick is that
you're defending this scumbag when
meanwhile are actual political activists
who were having their anonymous
anonymity stripped away from them and
they're being fronted a fucking prison
cells and there are hacktivists or
having the same thing done to them.
Like Jeremy Hammon, I think his
name is, and you don't see any,
you don't see any upward or on reddit or
Digg about that shit because it's like
people were like, there's
a disconnect. You know.
What about Obama prosecuted more whistle
blowers in any other administration
combined easily an antiquated law from
world war one 1917. What's the law?
The espionage act for spies during World
War One. They charged Thomas Drake,
some guy who was an NSA whistleblower,
but an illegal torture and spine
program and they fucking tried to, uh,
put him in jail for 20 years
for it has to be matched.
Bradley manning the same thing, which
could have the death penalty. I mean,
that's a very serious charge. Aiding the
enemy to not that hope he changes it.
Yeah,
it's pretty intense.
What do you guys see happening
in the future? What do you,
how do you see this playing out?
Do you have any idea?
Is it ridiculous to even guess,
but it seems that we're building
towards an event. It doesn't,
it doesn't seem to me that,
you know,
we can continue with all these
various aspects, the continual, uh,
the wars overseas,
the battle for resources,
the crazy people that we have representing
us that don't seem to have anything
in line with our own personal needs or
our own wants or desires as a nation.
It seems like we're being led.
We're on a pirate ship,
we're on this crazy fucking
pirate ship and we're slow.
We're about to hit the rock somewhere.
I think, uh, I always tell people,
I mean people who vote in the
presidential elections and,
and think that there's going to be some
sort of change that can never happen.
It's only coming from grassroots
is only coming from the bottom up.
And I think that if you,
you just acknowledged that voting
is something that you do every day,
multiple times a day.
I mean everything you do is politicize.
Everything you'd do can,
can have an impact.
So I think the conversations you have,
the dialogue you engage
in as the business,
as you choose to support the websites
you go to, the media you consume.
I mean all of that is an act of voting.
All of that can enact some sort of
change. And so it's just, it's just,
it's easy to get disillusioned
and disempowered from
getting sucked into these
fucking election cycles that are just
psychically van pampers thick. I Dunno,
it's hard
feel like you can have it have an
effect on something like a presidential
election maybe.
Like a lot of people feel like it
doesn't really matter if I go and vote.
What the,
where they can have an effect is
like what people like David like on a
congressional level and on in midterm
elections and specifically in primaries
where a lot of good,
perhaps good politicians get pushed out.
Dude,
if you can get in there and give us an
inside view of what the fuck is going on
with that machine, that fast
fascinate, I have my Google glasses on.
Just an insight to how the fucking
machine runs cause it must be way more
complicated than I imagine it must be.
Just
I feel like there's a lot of,
probably like a ton of pressure
just coming down on you. Okay.
Very hard. You can't get there unless
you've already sucked the lizard cock.
But here's, here's the thing. If
he was going to bring you into a room
with a blizzard, fucking lizard cognitive,
well,
the model that we're basing this on is
a little bit different from the Lizard
Cock sucking model. It's improved. Uh,
if we get lots of
contributions from individuals,
like tens of thousands of small
donations from real people,
you're beholden to those people.
Instead of being beholden to the,
like NPA or the defense lobby
or any other shit or Israel,
US relations lobby,
you're now only beholden to the people
who actually help get you into office and
your constituents.
And that's the way representation
is supposed to work in this country.
And it no longer does that.
Cause most people feel powerless.
Most people have never given $20 to
anything in their life that is political.
There are lot of people go,
I don't like politics.
And they didn't give money to Ron Paul.
They're not giving money to Gary Johnson
or any of these people who if you were
to give them money,
it would make a huge difference.
But how sad is it that
that's what it takes? Well,
money's been elections and
politics since the dawn of time.
Unfortunately we have super pacs are
new and fucked up and that needs to be
reversed as soon as possible.
We need to clean election system and like,
but there's other ways. I mean, it
doesn't have to be that way. Well,
it would be nice if people could
vote online. It seems silly. Yeah,
exactly. Thank you. No,
it doesn't make any sense.
If you mommy murder money's safe online,
really come on the fucking billions
and trillions of dollars that are moved
around with ones and Zeros
and they haven't hacked that.
But you're saying they can hack.
Well,
they've already hacked your
fucking voting machine,
so those things aren't good either.
How could that be?
So little transparency and these bulky
boxes, like you can't see how it works.
We count it. There's no backup.
There's no verification.
And if you've ever watched hacking
democracy and then you watched die bolds
change of their name after that dot.
That hacking democracy,
Hbo Show where they showed how those
fucking machines are set up for a third
party input to alter the number.
You can alter the numbers. Yeah,
you can change it and like by 10% or
something crazy. That should be illegal,
by the way.
[inaudible] a corporation that's doing
evil shit and you just rebrand as
something else,
but you retain all the same
leadership in the same actual company.
That'd be like Charles Manson being like,
I'm going to rebrand is Chris,
whatever and then like he's out of prison.
Sadie becoming p diddy
like who are you really
ridiculous job,
but that's just hanging out with reggae.
Do you smoke a lot of weed?
You'll think you're a cat. Also,
the CEO of Diebold told Bush at a
campaign event. He was just like, we,
you will get in.
You know the president.
I know I need mushrooms. They all
need to be taken away. I live in DC.
I am just like,
I just want to dose all the politicians
there and like all the CIA should be
able to get into politics and I don't
think like once you leave politics you
should be able to go work
for the corporation. Yeah.
The were like Supreme Court
justices that go work.
Like they'll overturn a law
and then they'll go join a
corporation that benefits
from it.
Of course we'll,
how about people that construct financial
studies that that benefit people in
Wall Street and then there,
there are universities when they do this
then they get out of that and they get
jobs with these very firms that they've
helped protect and make money from it.
And you find out that they're making
millions of dollars, you know,
working for these corporations
now are the opposite.
Like Halliburton and Dick
Cheney obviously that was,
that'd be the biggest example. The
most ridiculous whenever, right.
A guy who's a CEO of a company that
fits his shit after it gets blown up,
gets in office and then decides to blow
up everything and then give them no bid
contracts to fiction and
they did a horrible job too.
I just watched something on that the other
day where they were talking about the
quality of the water,
like the quality of the services they
were providing the soldiers but it was
just ridiculous.
And then you sounded like burn pits cause
they had like they would like take all
this,
all this,
all this equipment that was bought by
taxpayers and it was just like chunk it
away like the waste or is just phenomenal.
It's because the more they spend,
the more they got paid.
Now I have to bring this up because it's
been discussed online and you explained
it all, but there was like
some discussion that you,
you were misrepresenting
where you were running.
There was a confusion as to where,
just so everybody knows
what the actual facts are,
where are you running for Congress and
when so people can support you. Sure. Uh,
the election is November 4th,
2014 I'm running in the 23rd district of
Florida will be no world. Then I said,
here's the,
here's the problem.
If you run as an independent candidate
and you decide last minute to jump in,
which is what a lot of independence do,
you get your fucking ass handed to you.
So instead we're being very deliberate
and slow and careful and gradually
building this thing out.
We've already had like 110 people sign
up to volunteer or volunteer to help us
campaign. And uh, we're raising donations.
We filed with the FEC but
we filed with the IRS.
We have all of rough financial stuff
figured out and the chaotic dotting all of
our i's,
crossing our t's.
So that's why we're running so early
because we actually want to win.
This isn't some halfassed independent
campaign and make a point.
It's to actually win.
And I had never said I was running in
2012 what happened is I did a Reddit Ama
were a couple of guys swooped in and I
think it might have actually been one guy
with two usernames and they kept
saying his campaign's a fraud,
don't contribute to it. It might even be
illegal to contribute to this campaign.
They're saying this shit.
And then as soon as I saw it,
I replied and explained everything.
And there was some confusion about the
district cause it was previously called
the 20th district. And so at first
our website did say 20th district.
It was redistricted. I mean
redistricting is incredibly complicated.
I don't fully understand it, uh,
be honest about that. But, uh,
so I responded, any rational person
who read that would say, okay,
this explains everything. But then
these guys down voted that comment.
So it was buried. If you were skimming,
you're like, why didn't he answer this?
And then they would post it again and
I would comment again and they would
download it like negative 10 votes and
then that was, I was like, this is fucked.
Like I'm done with the Reddit Ama
for today. Cause it was so good.
And then a couple people
went in and ruined it.
You think that that could be people that
look at you as a potential threat in
the future and they want to try to
squash him now I don't know if I'm that
important yet. I think they're
just assholes to figure out.
There's going to be a certain
point in time when you are,
there are trolls out there and it,
there are trolls out there and they
do love to take people that, yeah,
they see somebody who's putting their ass
on the line and they don't really like
that cause it calls them out.
You know that they're just sitting there
criticizing other people will also,
you're, you're smart and
what you're saying is pretty
fascinating and what you're
saying,
you have a lot of conviction behind and
people don't like people that are better
than themselves.
They know they're going to like someone
who they can't like look at him and look.
They look at what I've done in my life
by the time I'm 26 and I'm kind of a
fucking loser compared to this guy
whose last name is seaman. Fuck.
The last name is ridiculous.
Yeah, but you've got to keep,
I'm not going to change it.
You've got to own what you are.
My last name is fucking just like,
you should change it to that David.
Just warm,
just like David Seaman.
Do you really want a man in office with
the last name sperm that's going to,
is that going to be a part of a
campaign against you? Is Mark? In fact,
if anything, the last thing probably
helps with young voters, but uh,
David voted against the Patriot Act white
splatter on the screen to be serious
for a second.
What's really important about my campaign,
it's not even that one person
out of 435 member house.
It makes that much of a difference
aside from being able to introduce
legislation,
which will make a difference.
But the big thing is if
this actually happens,
we're going to create a
handbook and distribute it
to other people around my age
and in anybody's interested in running
and not interested in affiliating
themselves with super pacs are with
lobbying groups or with one of the two big
parties. You show them the handbook
of here's how it can be done.
Use the Internet instead of a party.
Raise small individual donations.
Remain relatively honest.
Don't fucking sell out six months before
the election to the Koch brothers or
something. And if you release
this handbook and you go,
this has been done before,
here's the,
the recipe.
So many people will flood into congress
who are more like more like you and me.
Just actual people who are pissed off at
the way things are going and feel like
if we had some rationality in there
and things would get better and you're
already seeing that happening, like
it's going to happen. It's just,
I'd rather have it happen two years from
now instead of 10 or 15 years from now.
Do you think that you have to worry
about your safety with this plan in mind?
Do you think about that at all?
What I'm doing is a great thing and I
mean to worry about your safety for just
trying to improve the country. Isn't
that crazy though? It is crazy.
I bet people say like,
you're probably on some lists now
and I used to be like kind of, uh,
Alex Jones about, about that. I was
like, Shit, I probably am on some lists,
you know? But now I think it's kind
of, I'm kind of flattered by it.
If the government's reading my emails
and my texts are probably a little bit
impressed that Dell and I have marshaled
this kind of support this far out and
that our, our campaign is really
just about what we say it's about.
It's not actually secretly backed by
the clean coal lobby or some bullshit.
It's just the campaign of people who
want to see better representation and
that's all it is.
So if they're watching you,
they're probably a little bit impressed,
no longer afraid of, you know,
having somebody Julian Assange be by
hooking me up with some like hooker or
something and the taping it, you know, if
that happens free hooker, I dunno, Hooker,
um,
I mean this,
but if you look at what this a NSA
building that they're putting together in
Utah,
that's going to spy on everybody you know,
and store all your data for all your
emails and text messages and all that
craziness. I mean that to me seems
like they think everyone's a threat.
So your threat to dude, if
you're on the show, well that's,
that's why we got do this now is in
like within next two years instead
of 15 years from now we won't have,
we won't have a republic cause it's going
to be, oh you want to run for office?
Let's pull up these emails that we have
in our NSA database of you saying this
pretty scandalous shit to somebody.
What do you want?
You want us to go public with this because
then it's going to run your campaign.
Then you go, okay, I'll
resign. Is there a way
change the tone of this country?
Is there a way,
I mean because of the tone of this
country clearly changed on September 11th
clearly it did. It went
dark. Everything went crazy.
We realize the repercussions of what
the fuck we're doing. I mean if, if,
whether or not it's a, a, a false
flag event and they, you know,
they orchestrated it or
terrorist hate us so much.
They're willing to fucking sacrifice
people's lives and fly people into
buildings.
Whatever's going on.
We realize there's repercussions to
whoever is in office, being an office,
whoever is in government, whoever's
in conducting world affairs, who else?
There's obviously some fucking chaos
because they wanted to make a big noise.
They wanted to make a big splash
and kill a bunch of people.
There are two. How can that change?
Two things that could change.
One is shows like yours where you're
opening real conversations and shows like
yours where the people on TV with Abby
Martins shell, you know you're like, oh,
she's kind of like me. She's
not some last robot, she's not.
Some plastic person is just being fed
these Fox News talking points and you
probably know at the end of the day,
at the end of the day that you're at the
very least distracting people from the
real issues. I'm sure those people go
home knowing that and they go, well,
I'm getting paid $3 million to do it,
so who really gives a shit, you know?
And that that's the first thing.
The second thing I think is a,
you just have to keep going.
Like,
you can't stop just because
there are some issues out there.
I feel a lot of people,
there's a silent majority who is fed
up with the TSA groping them and fed up
with US spending this much money on
programs that we maybe don't really need.
Well, the problem with the surveillance
data is the chilling effect.
It makes people a stifled
into not dissenting,
not speaking out as much because
when, you know, if you have a mic,
if you have a recording device on a table,
you're not going to say the
same things as you were before.
And so when you know that you're
being watched everywhere, um,
recorded everywhere,
surveilled, uh, data, mind,
you're not going to speak out as much.
I've heard I've had so many people say,
you know, aren't you terrified? And
I'm like, I'm just speaking the truth.
I'm just speaking what I
believe and, uh, you know,
talking about what I'm
passionate about and if,
and if everyone kind of shed themselves
of that fear and didn't let that affect
the way that they acted, then I think
that the country would be a lot different.
They're not going to be able to
hold on to that kind of power.
I don't think it's going to be exclusive
to them. I think the Internet, the, the,
the, this, just this sort of intertwining
of information into our lives.
I think it's going to get to a point
where there's just this zero point, well,
there's this point of,
you know,
what Terence Mckenna called ultimate
novelty or we're going to reach some new
paradigm, new shift in
English. Yes. Look, we look at,
we can do now,
but just with Google and cell phones
and just the ability to talk to people
where you're driving
your car home and see,
it's really a crazy connectivity that
we've sort of taken for granted because
it's just Bluetooth in my car.
It's kind of cool,
but you get used to it after awhile and
you do business while you're stuck in
traffic. But that's a, it's,
it's a weird thing and that's
just what we know exists.
Could someone invented it? They
haven't stopped doing that. Okay.
They're going to continue and they're
probably on the cusp of releasing some
shit over the next decade or so.
That's going to make that
look like nothing and then
no one's going to have any
privacy and we're going to have to accept
this whole idea of like humans being
one. You know that the human race is
just one big gigantic super organism.
Well that's going to be real as fuck.
Like it's not just going to be some
sort of a hippy dippy yoga phrase,
you know that you say because it makes
you feel better. It's going to be,
it's going to be real.
You're going to be able to see,
everyone's going to know the real live
repercussions of all sorts of different
types of behavior.
We're going to be able to see how
people really feel about each other.
We're going to see, you know,
how people really view you.
It's going to be very different
than life now and it's inevitable.
It's not gonna. It's not gonna stop.
Just like we were one point in time,
animals with no communication whatsoever.
We were one time single celled
organisms with no, you know,
no way of making any noise and we became
this thing and this thing is not going
to stay this thing forever. This thing's
going to be some wait fucking crazier.
So are all of our problems that we
have right now are the the monkey mind,
the fucking wild male dominant chimpanzee
mind that's trying to take over the
world.
While while this is happening,
technology is just moving closer and
closer in on it and it's scrambling and
they're trying to do the most arcane.
We can just lock them up for no fucking
reason. Yes, lock 'em up and they're,
they're doing all this things. It's
because the, the troops are circling,
people are circling.
There's like this big ant death spiral
of the more madness that we operate
under, the, the more access to
information than we have. The,
the crazier it's gonna get.
It's gonna get to a point where it can't
be contained because everyone will be
involved in it. It won't be as simple
as there's world bankers can tell the,
you know,
the troops to move into certain positions.
The troops are going to know
exactly where it's coming from.
Everyone's going to know
where it's coming from.
Everyone's going to know why it's coming
from, from, from, from whatever. You know,
whatever group is pushing,
whatever agenda that's forcing people
that die and they're going to be punished
for it.
There's just no way.
There's no way you can keep this fucking
game going on unless you bomb us back
to the stone age and it
only a few thousand people
survive, then it's possible.
So if you are real speculator,
and if you looked at like if you
looked at the human race and listen we,
there's no way we're going
to be able to keep this up.
We're going to have to do is build
something about five miles into the ground
and we're, we can keep you alive for
about three years. That's what we need.
And we need about a year for the
radioactive waste to die off.
And then we come up back to the surface
when most of the people are dead and we
start all over again.
Follow
the apparently this
part five minutes folks.
12 what is going to, I
can't, I can't keep going.
Yeah,
there has to be.
I don't think there'd be as many people
online trying to change things if we
were all hopeless.
I mean if we're very truly hopeless,
like people like Abby and dude,
like if you care about your country,
you like to see it do better.
Yeah.
You don't want to see it devolve into
a bunch of fucking Walmart parking
lots and protesters being beaten
and surveillance cameras everywhere.
I think our goal of mean to or being
like upbeat throughout this show,
like we failed. It's not
hopeless. It's ridiculous.
It's not hopeless.
It's just ridiculous.
The human society as we know
it is a temporary thing.
It's not going to stay this way camp.
It just can't [inaudible] this is the
way of fucking books and town meetings
where two people talk loud
cause they had no microphones.
This is the way of the small
tribes led by a few leaders.
Shit doesn't work anymore.
So it's a global world
environment we're living with.
That's what we're living with. But we're,
we're, we're, we're all connected now.
Does Jason Silva videos where it's
like an amazing future is technology is
uplifted us.
That's what happens if we actually do our
parts and speak out and take a role in
government, take a role in the media
and getting the truth out there.
That's what we get.
That's our reward.
If we actually do our roles as
individuals and as a community,
if we don't do those things,
we don't get that.
It's not just gonna magically happen.
I really don't believe that.
I think if we don't do our parts,
we end up in a place that looks more like,
I kind of like total recall
version of the future.
People are living in small
dingy apartments and there
are cameras everywhere and
see secretive police pulling
people away for no reason.
Just total bullshit power,
power to take,
take back the message and take
back everything around you. I mean,
we built everything. Human beings are
amazing creatures. Look when we're done,
I mean we have the ability to
take it back. There's also the,
the realization that we're not going
to be human beings forever. You know,
just like we weren't
rats forever after the,
the asteroids hit 65 million years ago,
there was just like rats.
Now somehow or another it became
monkeys and it became people.
There's not going to stay people.
It's just were clinging on.
We're imperfect beings, clinging to our
existence. And it might be that this,
this symbiotic relationship we have
with technology might mean that the next
form of life is an artificial one IP.
That we're here to put that into reality.
We're here,
we're,
we're the bees making the hive and don't
really know why the fuck we're doing it.
We're the animal that
pollinates the plant, where the,
where the thing that starts up the
next stage of life, emotionless,
something that doesn't, doesn't
have ego, doesn't use resources,
intentionally recycles everything and
doesn't reproduce more than it needs to.
And that's the next stage of life.
And the next stage of life creates
the next and it keeps going and going.
And we're just all cocky and shit.
And we think the only kind
of life is biological life.
And it could be that we're here to make
some new shit. And that we're just,
the things that stay alive until this
new thing comes online. So, and then
if that's the case, you congressional
Riendeau mean shit side unfortunately.
Well it's, I mean it does. I mean it's
something for now for us it means a lot.
John Connor, whatever his name is. John t
toward the guy. The time traveler. Fuck.
This fucking show has been a
drag. I'm sorry. Not Tomorrow.
We're going to talk about roids.
We're going to talk about, um,
we were bringing in victor contact,
who's the guy who got era.
He got arrested,
went to jail for the ball coast candle,
the Barry bonds thing and all those guys.
He got uh, steroids. It were undetectable.
She'd be fascinating. He's going to find,
tell us how many different
people are cheating in sports.
Apparently it's everybody
apparently like you.
You can't be a high level athlete unless
you're doing something that's funky.
If everyone's cheating, that doesn't
that mean like nobody's cheating?
I guess what I've always wondered,
just stuff like that.
I don't think it's everybody.
I think I'm exaggerating.
I think it's 80% of the people. But you
know, a lot of them are the best people.
I mean, this Lance Armstrong
thing, it's pretty crazy. You know,
at what point in time,
I mean,
how many different people you have
to get busted before you go, Hey,
are you guys all on that? Just
tell me the truth. Why did,
why did they wait this long as a
foreigner to attack a national hero?
They built this guy up and now
they have to tear him down.
I don't think they should have been done
after the second when I to do that with
helps to just over pot. No,
they didn't. No they didn't.
They never tried to prosecute him as
lost his living man. This is a big,
big difference. The witch hunt,
they're trying to take away his titles.
They've stripped him of, you know, all of
his Tour de France wins and apparently,
you know,
the,
it's American doping society
or anti-doping society
that's doing it or whatever
the fuck the name of their organization
is, their DEA, whatever it is, mad,
whatever it is. They, I
mean, they don't even,
they don't have the right to take it
away. It's not, they didn't award it.
I wonder what's going on with that. He
did something to somebody, you know,
maybe someone was like big Sheryl crow
fan and when he started banging Sheryl
crow like that's it. This motherfucker,
he's going down one ball and all.
They can take him down. They
can take anyone down. Yeah.
Well it sounds like he was cheating on
me and I'm not saying you shouldn't do it
because it seems like
everybody was doing it,
but it seems like everybody was doing
it. I mean, I don't know. Don't know.
I don't know. But the, the guys
passed a bunch of drug tests.
It seems to me that you're wasting a
lot of money going after some guy just
because a bunch of people said he did
some things and you got all these drug
tests that he passed. Could you imagine
if that was like with you at work?
You know, I fucking know David
Seaman's smoked weed, man.
We took the cleanse together.
You're like this son of a bitch.
This guy tested positive and you tested
negative and they'll go after you for
years and years and years after
you've already quit ups. I mean,
that's really what's going on.
He doesn't ride bikes anymore and they're
fucking still dragging this guy out of
jail or in the court rather. And they
finally, he's just quitting. I don't know.
But apparently we're gonna find
out tomorrow. Don't do that.
Stop confusing the shit out of me.
We're going to find out tomorrow
from Victor Conte, he's gonna,
he's gonna let us know.
And apparently there's a lot of different
ways to do it where it's not dangerous.
You can elevate your levels
of testosterone and all
these different substances
legally and healthily. He's going
to show us that to just get subs.
He sells stuff like Zma, zinc, magnesium,
zinc and magnesium supposed to up
your testosterone. I need that.
We all need that. Listen,
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much for coming here.
We have to have one with
just you and low alone.
We had a little bit of a scheduling
issue, Abby. So next time we'll do it.
Just you. Is that sound? Good. And we'll
do that. November. Yeah. Do that. Okay.
We'll do that. I remember. And Dude,
anytime you want to come back by yourself
to please you guys do on my mind.
Sometimes I would love to.
Do you Skype it or do you do it live
or we could do a live before I leave
California. When are you
leaving? Well, let's talk about,
let's talk after this at
fall. Abby Martin, Abby Martin
on Twitter. Uh, what is it?
The underscore seaman deep sea fuck heads.
He a man.
And if they want to go online,
it's David Seaman for Congress and they
can sign up to do like volunteer David
Seaman for Congress,
[inaudible] dot com.com.com and
they can sign up and volunteer,
donate or just learn more information
about what to do and stay posted folks,
because we're gonna,
we're gonna keep having guys like David
on and guys and gals rather like Abby on.
And you know, there's a lot
of things that I didn't know.
There was a lot of things.
I'm sure you didn't know either about
the way this world works and the more it
gets exposed, the less they can
keep doing it. It's nonsense.
We live in a fucking co raising world,
but if it wasn't for guys like you,
most people wouldn't know about it really.
So thank you very much for coming on.
Thank you very much for doing what
you're doing and you're showing our tea.
How can people fall up? Breaking the
set. Just check that out on youtube.
It's all archived on there. There
you go. You dirty fucks. Thanks.
Thanks for sponsoring
our show a on at.com.
Go do a o n n I t use a code named
Rogan and you saved yourself 10% off.
No, that's only, that's only for today
though, Dude. It's probably over by now.
What town was it? Seven
o'clock or something? Um, yeah,
if you are doing this on, what's Today's
date? What is it? The 16th of October.
If you get this, a 16th of October
of use, the the the follow on it,
code o and n I t follow on it.
You save 20% off today. All right. Um,
to morrow we will see you
with a victor contact. Oh. Um,
San Francisco and Seattle.
Greg Fitzsimmons just joined me,
so Greg Fitzsimmons is come with
me. That's awesome. Yeah. So yeah,
we haven't done the
road together like ever.
And Greg and I have been friends
since the fucking eighties. Yo. Um,
so we're doing San Francisco on November
2nd and Seattle on November 3rd.
It should be fucking s and uh,
that's it folks.
We had a desk squad show here tomorrow
night at the Ice House comedy club.
It will be me, Greg Fitzsimmons
just had to back out of it.
He's going to some other place, I
forget where he's gone. Um, but Edwards,
Ian Edwards is going to be here.
Duncan Trussell of course Brian red
band and I will probably call some other
friends and have them come by as well.
It's always a good time here
at the Ice House in Pasadena.
It's only 15 bucks and it's 10 o'clock
on Wednesday. All right. Fucking freaks.
We'll see you tomorrow.
And then we got another one.
Tim Pools coming in on Thursday. Shit.
It's going to be crazy. All right.
We love you guys. Thanks
for everything. [inaudible].